Bekommen wir langsam Klarheit an der Tabellenspitze? Schalke gewinnt in Elbersberg Düsseldorf, entlässt nach dem 1 zu 2 gegen Holstein Kiel Markus Anfang und holt Alexander Ende die Wortwitze. Sie haben uns das ganze Wochenende versüßt. Wir sprechen darüber mit Anna Lautenbach und Lisa Höfer und jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerflieg vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf.
Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatur, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt zu dieser Ausgabe der Ligatur. Ich hoffe, ihr habt in den letzten Wochen noch nicht zu viel von mir gehört, in diversen Ausgaben dieses Formats. Denn– Spoiler– ihr werdet es im April nochmal tun, also freut euch drauf, I don't know. Aber wie immer sitze ich hier nicht alleine, das heißt, es wird kein, weiß ich nicht, 90-minütiger Monolog und das ist auch gut so, denn ich freue mich wirklich riesig, dass wir hier heute in unserer schlechten Laune bezüglich unserer Vereine mehr oder weniger vereint sind. So haben wir uns diese Folge auf jeden Fall schon selber angekündigt, also ganz top. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück nach ihrer Olympiapause durch ihre Arbeit für die Sportschau. Hallo Lisa Höfer.
Hallo zusammen, hallo in die Runde. Und ich freue mich, wieder mal mit am Start zu sein.
Ja, und sie benötigt, glaube ich, wenig Vorstellung. Ich darf außerdem Anna Lautenbach vom Eintracht Braunschweig Podcast gegen gerade hier begrüßen. Hallo Anna.
Hallo zusammen. Ich freue mich wirklich sehr, sehr doll. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, und da es gerade in dieser Phase wirklich müßig ist, in der Saison immer über alle Vereine zu sprechen oder über alle Vereine, um die es oben noch was geht oder unten noch was geht, haben wir uns erneut auf eine Hand voll von Spielen, besser gesagt vier Spiele konzentriert, zwei direkte Duelle oben, zwei unten. Aber bevor wir darüber reden, hat uns ja die Liga so ein paar Nebenschauplätze geliefert zuletzt. Und dafür starten wir in Karlsruhe, denn da wurde letzte Woche bekanntgegeben, dass Christian Eichner den KSC nach sechs Jahren im Sommer verlässt. Eine Trennung, Anna, die sich vielleicht gar nicht mal unbedingt sportlich, aber dafür Haus auf Karlsruhe mäßig angedeutet hat seit dem Winter.
Ja, irgendwie schon. Also ich fand, das war so ein bisschen Entlassung auf Raten, oder Entlassung nicht. Eine Veränderung auf Raten, also dass da irgendwie was passieren würde. Das hat sich irgendwie schon abgezeichnet. Ich finde es irgendwie schade. Also ich habe Christian Eichner sehr, sehr einfach gerne in der Liga gehabt. Mal schauen, vielleicht bleibt er ja auf einem anderen Trainerstuhl der Liga erhalten. Die große Frage, die diese Entscheidung für mich aufwirft, ist, was will Karlsruhe? Weil, also, haben die dann schon jemanden in petto, der ein ähnliches Niveau hat, der eine ähnliche Ausstrahlung hat? Also es wirft bei mir wirklich viele, viele Fragen auf, weil für mich in den letzten Jahren der KSC wirklich sehr, sehr eng verknüpft war mit diesem Trainergesicht. Und auch der Kader mit seinen Zweitligaschlachtrössern sehr eng in dieser Performance auch mit Christian Eichler verknüpft war. Und da bin ich sehr neugierig, was da gestaltet werden soll, weil ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann, dass ein Einschnitt von dieser Größe so massiv vorgenommen wird, ohne jetzt schon eine Vorstellung zu haben. Aber viele Fragezeichen, die sich darum ranken.
Ja, da würde ich mitgehen. Und wir haben tatsächlich mal bei Jörn Kreuzer nachgefragt. Den kennt ihr hier schon vom Hinrundenrückblick. Da haben wir ihn nämlich auch mal befragt zu der ganzen Situation damals. Und Jörn war so nett und hat uns das Ganze ausführlich mal erläutert und erzählt erstmal so ein bisschen den zeitlichen Rahmen für alle, die es vielleicht nicht so mitbekommen haben. Und was eben alles so seit Winter eigentlich beim KSC so los ist. Also hier der erste Part von Jörns Analyse zur Situation.
Was ich im Dezember beim Hinrundenrückblick schon geahnt habe, ist jetzt eingetreten. Christian Eichner wird 2026, 2027 nicht mehr auf der Trainerbank des KSC sein. Am Ostermontag gab es erste Presseberichte, dass sich der Verein überlegen würde, die Zusammenarbeit zu beenden. Offensichtlich war zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Beirat noch nicht informiert bzw. eingebunden, sodass quasi die Meldung dann erst am Mittwoch offiziell wurde, dass man die Zusammenarbeit mit Christian Eichner beendet. Geschäftsführer Sport Mario Eggimann war dann auch auf der Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel gegen Arminia Bielefeld, begründete die Entscheidung vor allem damit, dass man neuen Impuls setzen wollen würde, dass die Entscheidung länger gereift sei. Und ich glaube, an der Stelle war dann für mich klar, dass es definitiv eine atmosphärische Geschichte war, weil trotz diverser Nachfragen der Journalisten konnte Mario Eggimann inhaltlich das jetzt nicht so richtig begründen. Es fiel sehr oft, wie gesagt, der Begriff Impuls. Da hätte man ein super Trinkspiel machen können. Und ich glaube, dass die ganze PK dann ihren Höhepunkt hatte, als Mario Eggimann sagte, man wolle ja auch mit der Entscheidung den nächsten Karriere-Schritt von Christian Eichner ermöglichen. Das war mindestens kurios. Christian Eichner gab auf dieser PK auch diverse Winke mit dem Zaunpfahl noch mal Richtung Verein. Und Mario Eggimann, er sagte zum Beispiel in Beschäftigung mit dem Gegner Amina Bielefeld bezüglich seines Kollegen Mitch Kniart, dass man ja auch bei Bielefeld sieht, wenn zwischen einer Mannschaft und dem Trainerteam kein Stück Papier passt, dann müsse man immer auf Kontinuität setzen, weil sich das auszahlen würde. Wie es beim KSC lief, hat man ja gesehen, spätestens ab Dezember war das Vertrauensverhältnis, glaube ich, massiv beschädigt durch die Entlassung von Zlatan Bayramovic. Da hat man quasi dieses Universum zwischen Mannschaft und Trainerteam von außen so ein bisschen zerstört. Und dass man das nicht mehr eingefangen bekommt, die Dynamik, die man da entfacht hat, führte jetzt für mich zumindest zu einer folgerichtigen Entscheidung. Weil ich hatte ja im Dezember darüber spekuliert, ob Eiche vielleicht von sich selber dann zurücktritt, weil er sich das nicht mehr antun will am Saisonende.
Finde ich schon mal ehrlich gesagt ganz spannend, weil das, glaube ich, eben Anna auch vieles bestätigt, was du schon gesagt hast, beziehungsweise was eben bei uns auch im internen All-Star-Team-Chat so ein bisschen besprochen wurde. Für mich ist halt wirklich auch so ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht es denn jetzt eigentlich weiter? Ich fand es sowieso erstmal sehr spannend zu sehen, wie reagiert eigentlich die Mannschaft, wie reagiert das Publikum am Freitagabend? Da muss man sagen, gut. Also sie haben eben am Freitagabend 4 zu 1 gegen Amina Bielefeld gewonnen. Die Fans, die haben auch ausgelassen gefeiert. Also ich war selber da. Dafür fährt man gerne 850 Kilometer. Die haben, glaube ich, bis Stunde nach Abpfiff noch gesungen. Also da war schon, du konntest schon so ein bisschen merken, da ist im Stadion noch so ein bisschen eine Last abgefallen, weil man jetzt schon sagen konnte, das waren drei sehr wichtige Punkte, um eben so diese Saison jetzt auch so ein bisschen ausklingen zu lassen. Aber jemand, der zum Beispiel auch super wichtig war, war Marvin Wanicek. Und über den und wie es eigentlich in Zukunft jetzt weitergehen soll bei dem KSC, dazu hat uns Jörn auch noch ein bisschen was gesagt.
Vollgerichtet bedeutet aber meiner Meinung nach nicht richtig. Für mich ist die Entscheidung trotz allem falsch. Christian Eichner war immer der stabile Punkt in den letzten Jahren beim KSC. Er hat unter verschiedenen Geschäftsführern Sport gearbeitet. Es gab diverse Themen neben dem Platz, Stichwort Haus auf Karlsruhe. Er hat es immer wieder geschafft, eine Wagenburg zu schaffen, indem die Mannschaft ihre Leistungen auf den Platz gebracht hat. Er hat es auch geschafft, junge Talente zu fördern und so weiter und so fort. Von daher hätte ich mir lieber gewünscht, dass der Impuls nicht auf der Trainer-Position passiert, sondern vielmehr im Kader. Ich glaube, das ist auch das große Thema. Wo will man mit diesem Kader hin? Ich glaube, diese Saison war der Kader gerade so konkurrenzfähig. Christian Eichner hat speziell in der Rückrunde noch mal gezeigt, was man aus diesem Kader rausholen kann. Wo das Damoklesschwert der Entlassung permanent über der Mannschaft schwebte, ist der KSC aktuell Rückrunden siebter, obwohl es auch– keine Frage– schlechte Leistungen gab, wie gegen Nürnberg beispielsweise. Aber ich glaube, die große Frage ist wirklich, wo will man hin? Die wirtschaftliche Strategie ist klar, man will mit jungen Spielern Geld verdienen, aber was ist die sportliche Ausrichtung? Will man wirklich auf Dauer ein Durchlauferhitzer sein, also junge Spieler holen, die möglichst teuer verkaufen? Oder entwickelt man selbst eine Idee und entwickelt auch das Gerüst weiter? Wie tiefgreifend die Entscheidung gewesen sein könnte, sieht man ja allein an der Reaktion von Kapitän Marvin Wanezek, der nach dem Bielefeldspiel gesagt hat, er muss das erst mal alles sacken lassen und wird dann mit den sportlichen Verantwortlern noch mal am Ende der Saison reden. Ja, schade, dass Christian Eichner weg ist. Für mich eine falsche Entscheidung und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, für mich ist eben auch die Frage, also ich glaube, wir haben vielleicht momentan ein Beispiel, wo man so ein bisschen sieht, was das Problem ist, wenn du keine sportliche Identität so richtig hast. Und das ist für mich so ein bisschen Borussia Mönchengladbach in der ersten Liga, wo man irgendwie ja so seit Jahren eigentlich so Umbrüchen hinterherläuft und den eigenen Anforderungen und ich meine, das könnt ihr alles näher in den Sendungen zur Bundesliga der Männer nachhören. Vielleicht auch einfach von euch beiden nochmal die Meinung, wie seht ihr das bei Karlsruhe? Also seht ihr da so eine Gefahr, dass man eben vielleicht einen Umbruch herbeiführt, ohne wirklich schon dahinter eine Strategie zu haben?
Ich glaube, es ist schon ganz smart, vielleicht vom Ziel heraus zu denken. Und ich glaube, ich war nicht ganz alleine auf dem Posten vor der Saison, zu vermuten, der Casting möchte eigentlich gerne im Aufstiegsringen mitmachen in dieser Saison. Vielleicht ist das auch Nährboden dafür, dass da eben so viel Unzufriedenheit entstanden ist. Und dann im Winter eben diese, was wurde beschrieben, die atmosphärische Krise, die da ausgelöst worden ist, die da jetzt die nächste personelle Veränderung zur Folge hat. Und ich denke, ja, okay, aber ein Bundesliga-Aufstieg kommt ja nicht aus dem Nirgendwo. Also wäre das nicht vielleicht sogar sinnvoll gewesen, den irgendwie mit Christian Eichner zusammen strategisch irgendwie mit punktuellen Kaderumbrüchen zu gestalten. Ich habe so ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass man sich damit vielleicht überhebt. Also im Sinne von, es hat jetzt nicht funktioniert in dieser Konstellation. Man fühlt sich irgendwie so natürlich in höheren Berufen oder der Bundesliga-Berufen und denkt, mit einer solchen Entscheidung fällt einem das dann zu, wenn man irgendwie den wesentlichen Faktor verändert hat. Und daran glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also das habe ich zu oft scheitern sehen. Eine solche Vermutung, da irgendwie einfach qua Vereinsname eigentlich oben mitspielen zu dürfen. Ja und alles andere, was da jetzt eben gedacht ist, scheint eben offen zu sein oder auch nicht. Vielleicht erfahren wir das jetzt in den nächsten zehn Tagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich glaube der ganz spannende Punkt ist so ein bisschen, das ist das, was uns ja allen so ein bisschen als Fragezeichen über dem Thema schwebt. Was ist jetzt der Plan? Also ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen der Faktor, wollte man jetzt einfach nicht nur mit dem Trainer weitermachen und sagen so, man will jetzt hier diesen Cut oder hat man wirklich vielleicht schon mit ja einer größeren Vision geplant und weiß genau, wer soll da kommen, was ist jetzt das mega Picture. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das, das können wir gerade alle nicht abschätzen. Ich glaube, das wird total spannend zu sehen, wer da jetzt kommt und was dann irgendwie so die größere Philosophie und Strategie ist. Also was Jörg auch gerade ja ganz gut zusammengefasst hat, ist ja so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ganz, ganz viele Teams gerade in der 2. Liga so im Mittelfeld oder auch im Niemandsland haben. Du hast irgendwie den einen oder anderen guten Spieler, den kannst du nicht lange halten. Dann fängst du immer wieder von Null an, dann hast du vielleicht das nächste Talent, dann generierst du natürlich damit Geld, aber fängst irgendwie immer wieder von Neuem an. Kommt mir auch alles sehr bekannter an der Stelle. Bench, Lisa. Scheint ein Ding zu sein. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo ich sage, da war für mich der KSC gerade im Vergleich als Clubfan jetzt gesprochen, einfach ein total positives Beispiel, dass man eben nicht auf der Trainerposition auch noch jedes Jahr, jedes zweite Jahr einen neuen Kopf, eine neue Strategie, eine neue Philosophie hatte, sondern wirklich eine sehr, sehr gute, sympathische, sportliche, auch nicht unerfolgreiche, konstante und wenn die jetzt wegbricht, also ich finde es total spannend, in welche Richtung das jetzt geht, gerade wenn dann die Saison vorbei ist und wir sehen, was da vielleicht in Karlsruhe entsteht oder auch nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, wir sind uns eben einig, es kommt ein großer Umbruch darauf zu und man muss natürlich auch sagen, auch für Eggemann wird das natürlich dann auch interessant, weil er kündigt das jetzt alles an, er ist noch nicht so wahnsinnig lange da, er möchte irgendwie jetzt doch alles umkrempeln, wenn zum Beispiel ein Wannizek auch sagt, gut dann aber ohne mich, dann musst du das eben auch irgendwie auffangen und dann musst du natürlich ganz, ganz schnell gucken, dass du die Fans aber passend eingefangen kriegst, weil ich glaube, das ist was, was dann vielleicht fast ein bisschen unterschätzt wird. Du kriegst die dann, du musst dann aber wirklich auch eine Vision haben und das ist ja das, was ihr beide eben auch schon gesagt habt. Anna, gerne.
Ja und ich glaube, die Emotionalität ist auch wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen. Also im Braunschweig, diese Lieberknecht-Ära, das ist immer noch magnetisch. Also das ist immer die Referenz, das ist immer noch so der emotionale Anker oder das, was irgendwie Trost spendet in einsamen Nächten nach 4 zu 1 auswärts niederlagen. Und ich fand es erstaunlich, ich hatte das Spiel im Fernsehen gesehen, dass ich Christian Eichner immer wahrgenommen hatte als so sehr analytische Person, die sich auch durch extreme Spielverläufe, die der KSC ja auch am Anfang der Saison doll hatte, so mit 3 zu 3 und irgendwie in Dresden irgendwelche komplett absurden Szenarien da abgefeuert, bei mir aber immer aufgefallen war durch so eine Ehrsachlichkeit, der so emotional gewesen ist an der Seitenlinie. Ja, in einer Situation, in der das tabellarisch nicht mehr besonders relevant ist, dieses Ergebnis, das da jetzt erzielt worden ist, also für den KSC, ich möchte da jetzt nicht in Wunden rühren, dass ich schon den Eindruck hatte, dass da ja emotional auch viel bewegt worden ist und wenn du schilderst, dass da die Fans im Anschluss an das Spiel lange noch gefeiert haben, glaube ich, braucht man viel Fingerspitzengefühl und Feingefühl, das zu moderieren und die dann folgende Lösung tatsächlich auch verständlich zu machen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und man konnte ja auch so ein bisschen sagen, es war dann so eine Klammer, die sich auch geschlossen hat, denn mit dem Hinspiel, mit der 4-0-Niederlage damals in Bielefeld ging ja sportlich diese Talfall tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen los. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das dann vielleicht auch so, also die haben sich ja auch wie in den Rausch gespielt. Das konntest du dann sehen, mit den Fans im Brücken ging das dann auch gut voran. Und das ist natürlich, wie gesagt, das ist eine Chance, aber es ist natürlich auch ein großes Risiko und ich glaube, wir können sehr, sehr gespannt auf den KSC gucken. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, er tut sehr, sehr gut daran, sich frühzeitig, also gerade auch in Form von Aggie-Mann, aufzupassen, dass das keine Egonummer wird. Weil dann ist es, kommen wir in Haus auf Karlsruhe, Teil 386. Und ich glaube, das ist für uns vielleicht als Außenstehende ganz amüsant mit zu beobachten, aber für alle, die eben ihr Herz an den KSC hängen, ist es dann schon sehr müßig, weil per se muss man ja trotzdem sagen, es gibt so viele Nebenthemen beim KSC. Das Stadion, das gerade erst neubau ist, da gibt es richtig finanzielle bzw. bauliche Probleme. Das war jetzt voll, das will ich damit gar nicht sagen. Aber man hat sich dieses Stadion da ja auch als Neubau oder den Wildpark eben umgebaut, weil man wahrscheinlich auch sportlich eine Perspektive hat. Und da muss man natürlich immer aufpassen. Wir haben noch ein zweites kleines Thema, bzw. ich habe noch ein zweites kleines Thema, denn wir haben uns vorhin ein bisschen besprochen. Wir wollten es nicht ganz unkommentiert lassen. Es geht um das Topspiel vom vergangenen Spieltag, von Dresden gegen Hertha. Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, ich sage da jetzt ein paar Sätze zu. Wir machen das nicht als großes Diskussionsthema auf, denn erstens teilen wir eigentlich hier die Meinung größtenteils. Und zweitens ist es ein Thema, was auch im Forum und überall anders sehr emotional geführt wird. Dass es emotional Themen fühlen, ist per se nicht schlimm. Was aber schlimm ist bzw. nicht gerade zielführend ist, wenn man dann auch mit einer absoluten Haltung davor geht. Ich glaube, man kann sagen, erstens, ihr werdet das wahrscheinlich alles mitbekommen haben. Rund um die 20. Minute gab es einen gegenseitigen Angriff von Hertha und Dresden-Fans aufeinander. Pyrotechnik ist in Blöcke geflogen. Die Zaunfahrt oder ein Teil dieser Ostkurve, Hertha BSC-Fahne wurde entwendet. Die Fankur war dazu ein Statement auch abgegeben. Aber– und das völlig vorwegschieben– wir wissen, Stand anderthalb Wochen später immer noch nicht genau, was passiert ist. Wir brauchen nicht lange darüber diskutieren, wer hat angefangen. Das ist hier kein Kindergarten-Kampf. Wer hat angefangen, wer hat aufgehört. Aber ich möchte trotzdem einmal sagen, erstens– ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig– Gewalt gegen andere Menschen ist erstmal nicht gut. Außerdem– Pyrotechnik in Menschenmassen werfen absolut beschissen auf gut Deutsch gesagt. Es gibt nicht ohne Grund eigentlich den Kodex, Pyrotechnik verlässt nie die Hand. Punkt. Als Ergänzung dennoch dazu, halte ich es nicht für zielbringend, jetzt so ein bisschen in den Populismus zu verfallen und zu sagen, ja, das ist ja jetzt dann alles ad absurdum geführt worden, wofür die Fans kämpfen, die Stadien sind doch nicht sicher. Natürlich hilft solche Szene keinen. Es hilft auch nicht, dass sich 100 Nürnberg-Fans und 100 Dresden-Fans am vergangenen Wochenende treffen und dann von der Polizei festgenommen werden. Das spielt genau einer Partei in die Karten und das sind die Innenminister. Ja, und die Polizei, die damit natürlich auch ihre Begründung, bzw. oder die Länder, dass eben die Vereine die Polizeikosten übernehmen sollen, befürwortet. So. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass es wirklich wichtig ist, dass wir nicht immer in diese Verallgemeinerung und immer dieses ah ja, dann können wir jetzt hier, dann sollen einfach die ganzen Regularien kommen und mach doch alles, was die MK macht. Wir wissen das gerade mit Armin Twuster, da jemand sitzt, der da schon länger eine relativ strenge Position verfolgt, finde ich ein bisschen komisch, dass er dann auf einmal Zuspruch bekommt für Sachen, wo man vorher weiß, dass er eben sehr populistisch gehandelt hat, Zahlen nennt, die überhaupt nicht stimmen, etc. Wer dazu aber wirklich noch mehr hören möchte, und das sind einfach zwei Empfehlungen, ohne dass ich dem Inhalt zu 100% zustimme, einmal aus Dresdner Sicht, da gibt es den Schwarz-Gelb-Podcast von Jens Umbreit und Tino Mayer, die hatten Kearney Kuiper zu Gast, die sprechen, da gibt es leider keine Kapitelmarken, das heißt, ab ca. Minute 12 bis Minute 55 sprechen sie über die Ereignisse. Ich habe euch die folgenden Sachen alle verlinkt in den Show Notes. Und die Hertha-Base-Folge, da gibt es eine Kapitelmarke, die nennt sich Spielanalyse neben dem Platz, gibt es auch dazu. Und es gibt einen kleinen Kurzbeitrag von Sport im Osten auch, wo eben auch noch mal die verschiedenen Stimmen der Vereinsoffiziellen, der Polizei und von Armin Schuster aufgezählt werden. So viel dazu. Dabei möchte ich es auch eben belassen, weil wie gesagt, ich möchte das nochmal betonen, wir sind uns alle einig, das war eine absolut beschissene Aktion. Punkt. Trotzdem muss darüber diskutiert werden dürfen, inwieweit von anderer Seite her das Populismus genutzt wird, weil das können wir, glaube ich, alle uns auch einig sein. Auch das bringt uns nicht, weil nochmal, Kollektivstrafen treffen jeden, ja. Und inwiefern das wirklich hilft, sei mal in den Raum gestellt, auch weil wir eventuell bei Dynamo Dresden zum Beispiel auch schon gesehen haben, dass hat das halt, es gab da schon diese Kollektivstrafen, es gab Geisterspiele und es hat es im Endeffekt trotzdem auch bei wiederholten Male nicht verhindert. So, das ist keine Entschuldigung dafür, was passiert ist, aber das trotzdem einfach nur in den Raum gestellt. Ich freue mich wirklich über eure Diskussion darüber, aber passt wirklich bitte auch, dass ihr dann auch beim Thema bleibt. Dazu aber später nochmal mehr. So, kurzer Monolog, Part Eva, Ende. Sorry dafür, aber das musste einmal gesagt werden. Wir wollen jetzt tatsächlich wieder auf Sportliche gucken. Und dafür beginnen wir beim Spiel zwischen Fortuna Düsseldorf und Holstein Kiel. Endstand 1 zu 2. Holstein Kiel gewinnt 2 zu 1 bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und bleibt damit seit drei Partien unter Tim Walter umgeschlagen. Phil Harleres sorgt in der 50. Minute für die Führung für die Störche. Cedric Inten kann zwar zwischenzeitlich den Gleichstand erzielen. Ivan Nekic ist am Ende der entscheidende Torschütze in dieser Partie, auch wenn die Fortuna gleich dreifach geplagt ist oder sich benachteiligt führt in dieser Partie. Einmal ist Ugo's Klammer gegen Iguli für Jürgen Beck kein Grund, den Treffer zum 2 zu 1 nicht zählen zu lassen nach der Ecke. Es gibt außerdem kein Handelfmeter, nach dem Rosenbumm frühen Ball an die Hand bekommt. Zusätzlich muss die Fortuna gleich dreimal verletzungsbedingt wechseln. Erst muss Rasmussen nach einer Viertelstunde verletzt raus, vorher übrigens auch Kiel's Tolkien. Dann musste nach einer Stunde erst Raimund und dann muss Lija raus. Gerade bei Letzteren ist es ein Kreuzbandriss, wie inzwischen bestätigt, also richtig bitter. Die größte Konsequenz dieses Spiels ist allerdings, am Sonntagabend stellt Fortuna Düsseldorf Markus Anfang frei. Nachfolger wird er erst vor kurzem bei Preußen Münster, entlassene Alexander Ende. Ich würde sagen, wir schauen zuerst auf Fortuna Düsseldorf. Die stehen momentan auf Platz 14, 31 Punkte, 27 zu 45 Tore, 9 Siege, 4 Unentschieden und 16 Niederlagen. Zuletzt keine gute Bilanz, kann man glaube ich sagen. Also da ist es Platz 17 in der Formkurve, 4 Niederlagen am Stück, nur ein Sieg. Also 3 Punkte aus den letzten 5 Spielen. Lisa, ich fange mal bei dir an. Also schauen wir erstmal, ich würde sagen, auf die Personalie Markus Anfang. Er war jetzt insgesamt 21 Spiele in der Liga im Amt, dabei 6 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und 12 Niederlagen. Also er hat also fast alle, die Hälfte aller Spiele verloren. Zuletzt eben diese 4 Niederlagen gegen Braunschweig-Härter, Kaiserslautern und Kiel. Jetzt erstmal die einfachste Frage, sage ich mal, ist für dich diese Entlassung folgerichtig?
Ja, das ist ja immer die Gerätchenfrage. Hat es sich gelohnt am Ende des Tages oder nicht? Ich glaube, wenn man einfach nur auf die sportliche Tendenz guckt, du hast die Zahlen ja gerade ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ich habe mir auch so ein bisschen rausgeschrieben, was du gerade ganz schön auch zusammengefasst hast. Ich glaube, dann kann man das an der Stelle total verstehen, dass man gerade jetzt vor den letzten Spielen sagt, man versucht nochmal den Impuls zu setzen, man versucht nochmal eine Stellschraube zu drehen. Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen die klassische Übersprungshandlung, wenn man ehrlich ist. Deswegen, ich verstehe das. Ich weiß nicht, ob man nicht hätte schon– das ist natürlich jetzt sehr weit zurückgeblickt– ob man sich ganz generell mit Markus Anfang eingefallen getan hat. Das ist natürlich jetzt sehr, sehr weit zurück. Man muss da aber immer dran denken. Aus persönlicher Sicht das schöne Spiel Anfang Oktober. Düsseldorf gegen Nürnberg. Der Vibe war ja so ein bisschen der Verlierer. Bekommt Markus Anfang als nächsten Trainer? Und so kam es ja dann auch. Deswegen so weit zurückzugucken, hilft an der Stelle vermutlich nicht. Die Frage würde ich trotzdem gedanklich immer nochmal so mitnehmen wollen. War das an der Stelle der richtige Move, der richtige Mann? Ich verstehe jetzt die Konsequenz, die man zieht. Finde tatsächlich die Entscheidung mit Alex Endel sehr, sehr spannend und sehr, sehr mutig, um das vielleicht so zu formulieren, dass man sich aber jetzt von Markus Anfang trennt. Ja, das finde ich nachvollziehbar und in der Situation auch ein Stück weit richtig.
Anna, bei uns war gestern in der Gruppe auch so ein bisschen die Diskussion, ob es ganz fair gegenüber Markus Anfang ist, weil er natürlich auch diese ganzen Verletzungen immer dabei hatte. Würdest du sagen, es gibt trotzdem abseits der Verletzungen einen sehr guten Punkt, wo man sagen muss, okay, aber er hatte ja trotzdem vielleicht genug Zeit? Und andere Punkte, wo man sagt, das ist wirklich aus taktischer Sicht vielleicht auch ein guter Grund, ihn dann doch freizustellen?
Was ich glaube ich tatsächlich durchzieht, ist, dass die Fortuna einfach viel zu viele Chancen braucht, um überhaupt ein Tor zu erzielen. Und das ist Ergebnis besser geworden in der Phase, in der die Fortuna mit weniger Verletzungen zu tun hatte. Das stimmt schon, weil das ja eigentlich so seine Zeit bei der Fortuna in drei Phasen eingeteilt werden kann. Dieser bisschen holprige Start, wo wirklich wenig zusammenlief, man sein Spiel nicht erkennen konnte, die Ergebnisse auch überhaupt noch nicht gestimmt haben. Und dann stimmten die Ergebnisse und das ist ja dann im Fußball häufig so, dass das dann zur Folge hat, dass die Spiele auch besser werden, dadurch werden die Ergebnisse besser und das eine bedingt dann irgendwie das andere. Dann gab es Spiele, in denen Flo Kastenmaier rausrotiert ist, aufgrund einer Verletzung, die er sich im Training zugezogen hat. Das ist immer, finde ich, weiß ich nicht genau, wie zu simpel das ist, das auf sowas runterzubrechen. Ich aber schon glaube, dass ein Team, das eher taumelt, als gradlinig geht, solche Spieler dann vermisst, auch wenn er sportlich absolut souverän vertreten werden konnte. Und diese Talfahrt dann begonnen hat tatsächlich in Braunschweig beim ersten Spiel des neuen Braunschweiger Trainers Lars Konnetka. Das war, glaube ich, aus vielen Perspektiven so ein bisschen undankbar, weil einfach nicht klar gewesen ist, auf welches Team stößt er da, auf welche Art von Fußball stößt er da. Und die dann in Braunschweig 0 zu 1 verloren haben und dadurch wieder in diesen Abwärtstrend und Abstiegskampf gerissen worden sind. Ich glaube aber, dass Anfang grundsätzlich genug Zeit gehabt hätte, die Mannschaft so zu stabilisieren und einzustellen, dass ein 0 zu 1 Auswärtspleite in Braunschweig nicht Stein des Anstoßes für eine vierwöchige Krise ist. Ich finde es aber schon krass, tatsächlich, bei aller Vorsicht und allem, wir müssen jeden Stein umdrehen und wir müssen alles hinterfragen, weil die Situation so gefährlich ist, dass ein Trainer angeschlossen an eine Phase, in der man gesehen hat, wie er sich das vorstellt, vier Spiele verliert und dann entlassen wird und zu einem Zeitpunkt der Saison jemand kommt, der eigentlich auch ein bisschen Zeit braucht. Genauso wie Anfang von ein paar Monaten auch. Also so richtig klug, ich kann das im Grundsatz verstehen auf der einen Seite, so richtig klug werde ich aus der Vorgehensweise trotzdem nicht. Ob das jetzt fair ist, wie du gefragt hast, weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht bewerten, weil die Verletzung wird schon echt. Das wiegt schon sehr. Ich glaube, dass ein durchschnittlicher Zweitliga-Kader eine solche Anzahl an Verletzungen von wirklich Schlüsselspielern wahrscheinlich irgendwann einfach auch nicht mehr kompensieren kann.
Ja, finde ich auf jeden Fall interessante Punkte. Ich glaube, was ihm wirklich so am Ende den Job in Anführungszeichen gekostet hat, ist einfach, dass man ja einfach sagen musste, das konnte man im Spiel gegen Kiel ganz exemplarisch zum Beispiel beim 0 zu 1 sehen. Also diese komplett fehlende Zuordnung bei gegnerischen Kontern. Also das ist ein tiefer Ball, der einmal eben von der Seitenlinie geschickt wird. Da muss Lia da auch noch in den Zweikampf reingehen und kommt da eben einfach nicht mit hinterher, weil er natürlich irgendwie auch kein klassischer Außenverteidiger ist. Und da hast du schon gemerkt, also gerade dieser Außen, die waren schon ein Problem in dem Spiel und gleichzeitig irgendwie auch schon gesagt hat dann vielleicht selber vorne, dass man da eben nicht das notwendige Glück hatte. Ich meine, es gab natürlich auch immer wieder von Anfang auch diese Anschiebe um die Schiedsrichterentscheidung. Klar, also man kann es zum Teil vielleicht nicht komplett weglassen, gerade auch in dem Spiel. Ich glaube, dass man zum Beispiel diesen Handelfmeter pfeifen kann durchaus, dass man sicherlich auch, wenn das eine On-Field-Decision ist etc., man kann schon darüber diskutieren, ob es ein Foul ist vom 2 zu 1, aber trotzdem muss man ja sagen, Missnint hat das selber vom Spiel gesagt, dass es keine Alibis geben darf. Dass es natürlich ein Spiel ist, wo du zusätzlich zu diesen 2-Schiedsrichter-Entscheidungen auch noch 3 Verletzungen hast, das ist da so ein bisschen unglücklich. Da wirft sich für mich immer so ein bisschen die Frage auf, war es eigentlich egal, ob man nur dieses Spiel nicht gewinnt? Also, wäre er auch rausgeflogen bei einem 0-0, 1-1, 2-2? Das ist natürlich immer eine Frage und man muss natürlich auch sagen, zeitpunktmäßig, Anna, du machst da einen richtigen Punkt. Ich frage mich dann, was in diesen zwei Spielen gegen Kaiserslautern und Kiel so viel schlimmer war als nach den Spielen Braunschrank und Hertha, weil man muss ja ehrlich gesagt sagen, schon auch, also jetzt mal das Braunschrank-Spiel so, aber dieses Spiel gegen die Hertha, das war ja eigentlich schon auch noch mehr aufzeigend, wo die Probleme liegen und da hättest du ja noch eine Länderspielpause dazwischen gehabt. Und das ist für mich dann schon so ein bisschen die Frage, könnt ihr einfach mal an euch beide gespiegelt, was ist denn jetzt in diesen zwei Spielen so viel? Ist es die tabellarische Lage noch mehr, die sich verschärft hat oder was hat sich dann noch mehr verändert? Lisa, gerne.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist so dieses klassische Gesamtkonstrukt, das man ja total oft gerade in der 2. Liga und in so einer sportlichen Situation dann sieht. Also ich glaube, es fängt damit an. Man holt einen Trainer im Oktober und will eigentlich die Saison auf jeden Fall mit dem beenden. Also da überlegt man, glaube ich, obwohl ich jetzt auch noch keine Sportdirektorin war, vielleicht den ein oder anderen Spieltag auch noch mal länger und guckt sich das noch mal an oder kommt dann vielleicht auch in so einen Modus mit, wir haben ja viele Verletzte, Mensch, hier lief was gegen uns. Also das kann man ja auch immer sich so ein bisschen schönreden oder sich so ein bisschen rechtfertigen an der einen oder anderen Stelle, das ist glaube ich auch menschlich, aber wenn man sich jetzt die Gesamtgemengelage anguckt, dann kann ich so ein bisschen diesen Impuls jetzt schon verstehen, dass man sagt, okay, das ist jetzt eigentlich nicht unser eigentlicher Plan gewesen, das ist eigentlich vielleicht auch nicht das, was 100 Prozent Besserung verspricht, gerade wenn man sich dann jetzt eben ein Alex Ende holt und nicht einen klassischen Feuerwehrmann an der Stelle, da sprechen wir bestimmt gleich noch drüber. Deswegen kann ich das ein Stück weit schon verstehen, dass man das vielleicht nicht schon vor zwei, drei Spieltagen gemacht hat. Andererseits, was es jetzt bringt, ob das jetzt wirklich noch reicht. Ich habe hier mal eine Tabelle ausgedruckt, das ist so eng. Deswegen würde ich da ehrlicherweise jetzt auch keine Prognose geben wollen. Ich finde aber gut an der Stelle, ehrlicherweise, dass man ein Stück weit schon auch von Vereinsseite sagt, wir wollen jetzt nicht jede Woche darüber reden, wie schlecht wir irgendwie die Serie-Entscheidungen hatten oder wir wollen uns jetzt nicht jede Woche irgendwie selbst mitleiden, weil wir gerade so viele Verletzte haben. Also ja, das ist wirklich krass bei Düsseldorf. Ich habe mir das auch nochmal angeguckt, aber es gibt ja auch andere Teams, die mit Rückschlägen umgehen müssen. Und gerade wenn ich jetzt aus meiner Clubbrille zum Beispiel auf Dresden gucke, die ja auch mit einer B11 in Nürnberg angetreten sind, aber da haben auch einige Spieler gefehlt und die haben das trotzdem gezogen und da war trotzdem ein ganz, ganz anderer Vibe zu spüren als in Düsseldorf. Dann finde ich es umso folgerichtiger zu sagen, hey, wir können uns jetzt nicht, und das hat Markus anfangs für mich ehrlicherweise schon oft gemacht, wir können uns nicht immer hinter diesen Themen, die es gibt, ja, verstecken. Das hilft halt jetzt an der Stelle auch nicht, ne?
Anna, ich glaube, du wolltest auch noch was.
Genau. Und zwar hatte Miss Linthardt gesagt, dass er gerne verhindern möchte mit der Entscheidung, dass bestimmte Automatismen sich einschleifen und das fand ich irgendwie ganz interessant, dass du ja einen gewissen Zeitraum brauchst, um beobachten zu können, okay, das scheint irgendwie etwas zu sein, was sich jetzt tatsächlich wiederholt oder eine Gefahr zu sein, bei der die Mannschaft immer wieder einfädelt, in ähnliche Fehler hätten. Und dass er eben aufhören möchte, darüber zu sprechen, ob das vor dem 2.1. faul war oder nicht, sondern er möchte gerne, dass das 2.1. einfach nicht fällt. Und das finde ich einen nachvollziehbaren Wunsch. Irgendwie finde ich das trotzdem ein insgesamt seltsames Vorgehen. Ich auch immer noch nicht so richtig einordnen kann, wie die Mannschaft den Trainerwechsel im Herbst fand. Und dann ja auch wirklich einen großen Unterschied in den Typen, die die Mannschaft trainiert haben, vorgenommen worden ist. Wie die damit einbezogen wird, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das was gut ist oder nicht. Aber ich fand tatsächlich den Trainerwechsel in Braunschweig schon relativ spät dafür, dass da jemand geholt worden ist, der einfach nicht retten soll, sondern etwas verändern soll und aus dieser Veränderung heraus etwas bewirken soll. Und jetzt mit fünf Spieltagen und ich möchte gerne dieses absolut entsetzliche Restprogramm vorlesen, vor dem Fortuna steht. Nämlich spielen sie gegen Magdeburg, Dresden, Schalke, Elbersberg und Fürth. Das ist für ein Team in dieser Tabellensituation die absolute Hölle. Das ist ja nicht schön. Und ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt. Mir fällt wenig ein, was da irgendwie spielerisch jetzt in der Kurzfristigkeit tatsächlich nachhaltig noch so angepasst werden kann, dass das Team nur noch drei Torschüsse braucht für ein Tor und diese Anfälligkeit für Gegentore abgestellt wird. Aber wer weiß, vielleicht belehrt mich Ende auch eines. Ich verspare mir alle Witze.
Eines anderen.
Schön, dass du mir auch schon mal einen Job wegnimmst. Aber es ist sowieso sehr interessant. Also wir haben entweder jetzt immer so, das wird sich so ein bisschen durchziehen. Also gefühlt, entweder spielen alle noch gegen Kaiserslautern und Hertha. Also genauso die Vereine neben vielleicht noch, ich würde jetzt einfach mal schon mal sagen, Nürnberg und Karlsruhe. Für die ist es jetzt relativ…
Bist du optimistisch? Ich gucke immer noch nach unten.
Ich sage es euch, oh… Nächsten Samstag, das ist alles anders. Anders. Na, also ganz witzig, voll oft diese Kombination Kaiserslautern und Hertha wird irgendwie immer, zieht sich durch, ohne du spielst halt gegen direkte Duelle. Und wir reden jetzt schon die ganze Zeit um den heißen Brei. Wir wissen, Alex Ende wird der Nachfolger. Es gab eben Schwirte von Anfang an so ein bisschen in den Raum. Die Wortwitze, wie gesagt, sie waren natürlich wirklich gebrochen. Ende, Anfang, hieß das. Und da stellt sich aber jetzt eben die Frage, es ist eben kein klassischer Feuerwehrmann. Also nein, es wurde nicht wieder Friedhelm Funkel eingesetzt. Auch weil er natürlich so ein bisschen verbannte Erde beim letzten Mal entlassen hat, sondern Alex Ende kommt. Per se würden wir glaube ich alle sagen, interessanter Trainer. Allerdings wurde er erst vor drei Spieltagen bei Preußen Münster, also einem Mitabstiegskandidaten entlassen. Er hatte da selber auch nun, also eigentlich exakt den gleichen Punkteschnitt bei fünf Spielen mehr, bei den Preußen. Natürlich muss man sagen, wir wissen alle, am Anfang der Saison Preußen mit einem sehr schönen spielerischen Ansatz, wir brauchen das jetzt noch nicht mal in die Tiefe gehen, hat irgendwann nachgelassen, wo man auch sagen muss, lag es an Verletzungen, lag es daran, dass die gegnerischen Mannschaften sich darauf einstellen konnten. Er hat ein sehr, sehr klares System. Er spielt eigentlich immer ein 4-3-1-2-System mit so einer Mittelfeldraute, was vielleicht helfen kann, wenn wir über diese Außen, also gerade, wenn die Außen jetzt ausfallen. Das sind liebe Grüße an Thorsten auch in der Gruppe. Sowieso, Empfehlung habe ich euch auch verlinkt. Sie haben eine Sonderfolge quasi zur Entlassung und Neueinstellung rausgehauen. Gestern Abend noch sehr hörenswert. Könnt ihr gerne noch mal reinhören. Aber da ist jetzt eben die Frage, also es ist kein Feuerwehrmann. Ich glaube, per se würde ich erst mal sagen, das sind wir eigentlich auch light. Allerdings muss man ja sagen, Fortuna Düsseldorf ist jetzt nicht vielleicht wie andere Vereine da unten in der 2. Liga, die sagen können, okay, wir denken mehr perspektivisch, sondern für Fortuna Düsseldorf geht es ja eigentlich schon darum, dass sie unbedingt in der 2. Liga bleiben wollen. Wie, Lisa, ich fange mal bei dir an, bewertest du denn dann, als wirklich– reicht ein, zwei Sätze– Alex Ender als Nachfolger?
Ja, also den spielerischen Ansatz, ich glaube, das mögen wir alle. Das ist jetzt nur noch fünf Spieltage, das wird interessant, um es mal so zu formulieren, wie schnell er da, wie viel mitgeben kann. Mein Gedanke an der Stelle so ein bisschen, weil Anna das gerade auch angerissen hat, das ist halt auch ein ganz anderer Typ als in Markus Anfang. Und vielleicht ist es genau das, was jetzt an der Stelle auch hilft. Also das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen der, wenn man es optimistisch sehen möchte, vielleicht so der positive X-Faktor, das ist einfach eine andere Person, eine andere Persönlichkeit, obwohl ich jetzt auch Alex Ende nicht persönlich kenne, aber was mein Bild so von ihm angeht, ist, glaube ich, wirklich ein ganz, ganz anderer Mensch als Markus Anfang, auch eine andere Herangehensweise, glaube ich, auch in der Kabine mit den Spielern. Dass das vielleicht einfach etwas ist, was in dieser Situation jetzt hilft. Also ich hoffe sehr, dass es hilft, um das vielleicht persönlich mit reinzugeben. Ich fände es super schade, obwohl ich ja Wahlköllnerin bin, wenn Fortuna das nicht packt. Und ja, so eine richtige Prognose, glaube ich, traut sich keiner von uns zu. Dafür ist diese Liga zu verrückt, dafür ist diese Liga zu eng, dafür haben wir gefühlt auch schon Ergebnisse gesehen. Die hätte, glaube ich, keiner auf dem Tippschein vorher irgendwie gehabt. Aber ja, ich hoffe, dass es das, diesen positiven Vibe vielleicht einfach an der Stelle bringt. Weil ja, dass man jetzt in fünf Spielen da ein komplett neues System und die Verletzten und so, das hatten wir jetzt gerade schon ganz gut zusammengefasst. Das wird interessant.
Anna, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Ich glaube, ein Vorteil ist tatsächlich, dass er die Tabellenregion sehr gut schon kennt. Ich glaube, so etwas ist wirklich nichts zu unterschätzen. Was die Liga braucht, er hatte das in Münster gerade zu Beginn der Saison, finde ich, gezeigt, dass du mit einem Abstiegskandidaten in dieser Liga durchaus Fußball spielen lassen kannst. Dass das auch funktionieren kann, dass du nicht so spielen lassen musst, wie jetzt Münster gegen Fürth gespielt hat. Das ist nicht obligatorisch. Und ein destruktiver Fußball auch nicht gleichbedeutend ist mit Erfolg, sondern du durchaus irgendwie kreieren kannst. Und vielleicht funktioniert das in Düsseldorf besser als in Münster, weil die Spieler individuell ein bisschen besser sind? Ich glaube, es kommt jetzt eben darauf an, dass er die Köpfe da aufpäppelt und frei macht und die Jungs daran glauben lässt, dass sie nicht auf die Personen angewiesen sind, die jetzt gerade verletzt ausfallen. Weil ich glaube, wenn ein Trainer das immer wieder wiederholt, wir haben verloren, wir haben auch so viele Verletzte, heißt es ja im Umkehrschluss, wir können nicht gewinnen, weil wir so viele Verletzte haben und ohne diese Spieler funktioniert das nicht. Und das musst du, glaube ich, einfach, da brauchst du eine andere Geschichte, die du erzählen möchtest. Und es würde mich ehrlich gesagt überraschen, wenn der Kader der Düsseldorfer dafür nicht gut genug ist. Wenn sie da jetzt sofort in die Spur kommen, denke ich schon, dass das gut funktionieren wird. Wenn sie halt, also, wie gesagt, das ist so dieses Fragezeichen, wenn sie sich davon verabschieden, jetzt neu lernen zu wollen, sondern das quasi auf den Sommer verschieben.
Mein allergrößtes Problem ist, glaube ich, neben der Zeit einfach, jetzt mal ganz doof gesagt, aber weil alles so unten eng ist. Also wir fangen jetzt einfach mal, ich rechne jetzt sowohl Nürnberg als auch Bochum einmal kurz raus und fange mit Dynamo Dresden auf Platz 11 an. Dynamo Dresden Platz 11, 32 Punkte, haben ein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis, 47 Tore geschossen, 47 bekommen. Holstein Kiel, 32 Punkte auf Platz 12, 36 zu 43, also Torverhältnis von minus 7. Dann kommt der Minja Bielefeld auf Platz 13, 31 Punkte, 42 zu 44 Tore, minus 2 Torverhältnis. Dann kommt Fortuna Düsseldorf, auch 31 Punkte, allerdings ein Torverhältnis von 27 zu 45. Schlechteste Offensive der Liga geht noch, aber eben ein Torverhältnis dadurch von minus 18. Nur führt es schlechter. Wenn wir dann auf Magdeburg gucken, 30 Punkte, 46 zu 55, minus 9. Braunschweig, 30 Punkte, 31, 49, auch minus 18, führt 30 Punkte, 40 zu 61, minus 21. Münster, 31 zu 47, 28 Punkte, minus 16. So. Das heißt, Münster, der Verein, wo Alex Ende vorher war, die hatten eine ähnliche, weil also die beiden Spiele unter Aloui Schwart sind 0-0 ausgegangen. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf zu sprechen. Aber Alex Ende war halt ein Trainer der Mannschaft, die eigentlich vom Torverhältnis leider, ehrlich gesagt, auch ähnliche Probleme hat. Und das ist halt, du hast einfach nur fünf Spiele Zeit. Du brauchst eigentlich, so doof wie es klingt, aber mindestens zwei Siege, die du zu Null gewinnst und wo du ordentlich selber Tore schießt. Und das sehe ich irgendwie nicht. Weil die bringen jetzt keinen Unentschieden mehr. Anna, du hast das Programm aufgezeigt. Die bringen keinen Unentschieden gegen Magdeburg was. Die bringen keinen, also so schön wie es wäre, aber einen Unentschieden gegen Schalke. Du musst, Dresden und auch Dresden wird brutal schwer. Und das ist halt meine Hauptproblematik. Wären wir beim Winter gewesen und dann wäre Alex Ende. Andere Sache. Für mich komplett tatsächlich andere Sache, weil du dann vielleicht nochmal ihm die Spieler hingestellt haben könntest. Weil man muss nämlich auch, man darf wirklich, das will ich noch ganz kurz sagen, transfertechnisch müssen in Tat dann nicht ganz rausrechnen. Weil er hat von sich aus gesagt, wir machen mit Anfang weiter. Aber so richtig bis auf Tanaka waren die Transfers, ist jetzt ja ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Also das waren keine Soforthilfen. Das ist immer schwer. Das haben wir schon lange breit und diskutiert. Aber das ist für mich der Grund, warum ich sage, das ist vielleicht gar nicht Alex Ende Schuld am Ende. Aber ob das so klappt in dieser kurzen Zeit, das wage ich wirklich und vor allem, weil sie eben vor allem die direkten Duellen verloren haben, wage ich das so ein bisschen zu bezweifeln.
Na ja, und sie spielen ja wirklich gegen Teams, die gerne treffen. Also Magdeburg hat jetzt in Paderborn verloren, okay, aber 4 zu 3. Dresden ist sehr spielstark, Schalke müssen wir nicht drüber reden, Ebersberg auch nicht. Und alle Hoffnungen auf Fürth zu setzen am letzten Spieltag, weiß ich nicht.
Steigt ja auch nicht nur einer ab, ne?
Leider.
Also, und ob die große Rettung jetzt Relegation heißt, also ich meine, es ist halt, ich finde es sowieso, ich gehe da mit euch mit, da irgendwelche Prognosen wirklich abzusetzen, weil es so eng ist. Also es können halt auch keine fünf Mannschaften absteigen, ne? Also, zum Glück, sage ich da, glaube ich, für uns alle mal stellvertretend. Aber, also, ja, es ist wirklich, wirklich unfassbar schwierig und gleichzeitig gucken wir dann nämlich noch auf Holstein Kiel. Die sind jetzt eben auf Platz 12. Ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, 32 Punkte, 46 zu 43 Tore, 8 Siege, 8 Unentschieden und 13 Niederlagen, Formtabelle, auch Platz 12 mit 2 Siegen, 1 Unentschieden und 2 Niederlagen. Zuletzt schiebt sich eben mit dem Sieg vom Relegationsplatz weg, in Anführungszeichen, 2 Siege jetzt unter Walter gegen Bochum und Münster. Man holt Punkte in den direkten Duellen. Und das wird vor allem– ich prognostiziere das schon mal– nach diesen Partien gegen Kaiserslautern und Hertha BSC zunächst am 32. Spieltag gegen Eintracht Braunschalk nochmal spannend. Ich war am Anfang, muss ich sagen, es waren jetzt eben auch die ersten 2 Siege seitdem Tim Walther mitteilt diesem Unentschieden mittendrin. Die ersten 2 Siege unter Walther, ich tue mich ehrlich gesagt da noch ein bisschen schwer mit. Anna, das so endgültig zu bewerten, diesen Trainerwechsel bis jetzt, aber man muss ja per se schon sagen, das Konzept, was Tim Walther ihnen an die Hand gegeben hat, das scheint doch dann noch rechtzeitig angekommen zu sein, würdest du mir dazu stimmen.
Ja, würde ich zu stimmen, also die, glaube ich, Kritik, die formuliert worden ist, dass er zu pragmatisch Fußball spielen lässt. Ich glaube, das ist nur dann tatsächlich ein valider Punkt, wenn die Ergebnisse halt nicht stimmen. Also ich bin so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen, weil er nach dem Spiel jetzt gegen Düsseldorf, danach meinte, das sei absolut verdient gewesen, dieser 2-1-Sieg. Auswärts in Düsseldorf und das sehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also wenn du dagegen also den gleichen Auftritt lieferst, aber gegen eine Mannschaft spielst, die Souveräner trifft, geht das glaube ich anders aus. Ist jetzt viel konjunktiv, das ist schon klar. Das, was er halt offensichtlich sehr gut kann, ist zu verstehen, welche Punkte wirklich richtig wichtig sind. Und diese Spiele einfach dann voll konzentriert erfolgreich zu gestalten. Ist glaube ich zu dem Zeitpunkt der Saison ein bisschen heiß, weil kann auch nach hinten losgehen. Aber wenn es am Ende funktioniert, ist es völlig in Ordnung. Das war, worüber ich wirklich stolper, ohne jetzt hier zu tief in den Liga-Gossip eintauchen zu wollen, ist halt diese Genervtheit, die er an den Tag legt. Also diese Pressekonferenz, die da geteilt worden ist im Vorfeld, des Spiels in Düsseldorf, diese arge Kurzangebundenheit, dieses Abwiegen, dieses keine Einblicke gewähren und so. Das könnte ich verstehen, wenn er der Trainer wäre, der mit Kiel abgestiegen ist und der sich jetzt die ganze Saison irgendwie durch die regionale Unzufriedenheit pflügen muss. Aber er wusste ja, worauf er sich einlässt. Und ich halte den für ein Schlitzohr. Ich sage mein Schlitzohr. Der da irgendwie was im Schilde führt, Aufmerksamkeit auf sich lenken möchte, von der Mannschaft ablenken möchte, um ihm das wohlwollend auszulegen. Und bin sehr gespannt, ob und wenn ja wann in Kiel mehr zu sehen ist als Abstiegskampf. Weil ich das doch sehr, sehr, sehr aufs Ergebnis… Also natürlich geht es im Fußball am Ende darum, dass du gewinnst. Das ist auch mir klar tatsächlich. Aber so richtig viel Gestaltung sehe ich da in den Spielen aktuell noch nicht, sondern viel Reaktion und viel sich einstellen auf den Gegner, was aber eben funktioniert.
Ja, man muss halt in der Partie sagen, um vielleicht so ein bisschen weiter zu unterstützen in dem Punkt. Also das 1-1 fällt halt auch eigentlich nur, weil Weiner, man kann es glaube ich einfach als Torwartfehler bezeichnen, hält den Ball nicht fest, rutscht durch. Es gibt dann noch eine Situation, wo der Ball, ich glaube in den Innenpfosten und dann eben raus. Also das waren vielleicht wirklich am Ende so die zwei gefährlichsten Chancen, auch für die Fortuna, die dann wirklich die größte, also das Tor halt und das Ding danach. Also man kann, um glaube ich so ein bisschen Devil's Advocate zu spielen, schon sagen, gut, sie haben es halt über weite Strecken eben, also sie haben an dem Spiel die Effizienz gezeigt, die Fortuna Düsseldorf eben nicht hatte. Das reicht auch vielleicht einfach im Abstiegskampf und dann halt durch zwei ganz simple Sachen, also ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, Ball in die Tiefe, Querpass, Harris wartet am zweiten Pfosten rein. Dann gab es eine, also man muss auch sagen, eine gute Ecke von Duhumshu zum eben 2-1, wo man eben Kadiš, ne Kadiš, ne Kadiš, eben da am ersten Pfosten findet und der kann das dann durchschieben. Also, ne, ist dann auch glaube ich so ein Henna-Eil-Ding, war es so schlecht von der Fortuna verteidigt, war es gut von Kiel ausgespielt. Ich glaube, es ist immer so ein bisschen beides. Ja, ich gehe sonst aber, also ich gehe mit, da so die Frage ist, ich glaube, das bleibt ja auch bis heute so, gerade beim VfL Bochum, wenn wir da so ein bisschen die Querverbindung, auch wenn, ne, zu den beiden Absteigern ziehen, die natürlich viel früher ihren Trainer mit Uwe Rösler gewechselt haben, aber wo eben genau der gleiche Kritikpunkt so ein bisschen ist, so ja, okay, die Quick-Fixes, die hätte er so ein bisschen geschafft, aber wo ist die längere Entwicklung? Ja, und man kann eben noch nicht sagen, also es ist alles gut, sie sind raus. Also, wenn wir jetzt mal weg hier drauf gucken, ich habe die nächsten beiden Partien schon gesagt, dann kommt eben Braunschweig, ich sage euch gerade einen ganz schnell noch, wer danach kommt. Magdeburg und Dresden. Also, auch hier, wir wissen alle, irgendwann werden sich die Vereine da unten gegenseitig die Punkte wegnehmen. Das ist eine gute Nachricht für alle Vereine, die diese direkten Duelle unten nicht mehr haben. Das kann man glaube ich schon so sagen, weil irgendwann sind halt die Punkte weg. Aber es wird natürlich schon spannend. Also da gehe ich per se mit. Lisa, hast du dazu auch eine Meinung?
Ja, ich finde, ihr habt es schon ganz, ganz gut abgerissen. Ich muss jetzt gestehen, an der Stelle, ja, ich sehe da jetzt auch noch kein großes Ganzes oder eine krasse Entwicklung, ist aber glaube ich in der Situation auch tatsächlich zweitrangig. Das habt ihr ja auch gerade schon ganz richtig angemerkt. Am Ende des Tages ist mir als Kiel-Fan komplett egal, wie das Spiel gewonnen wird. Hauptsache, es wird gewonnen. Und das schafft Tim Walther ja jetzt gerade. Ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen das, wo ich auch sagen muss, das kann man positiv mitnehmen an der Stelle, so dass der Trend einfach stimmt und am Ende des Tages jeder Punkt, den du da unten drin machst, ob der jetzt verdient oder nicht so verdient ist, ich würde jetzt auch nicht mitgehen bei, es war ein hochverdienter Sieg gegen Düsseldorf, es war so ein bisschen, ich würde nicht sagen, Not gegen Elend, aber dem neutralen Zuschauer hat es jetzt nicht so furchtbar viel Spaß gemacht, würde ich einfach mal unterstellen an der Stelle, ist aber auch alles egal. Hauptsache, du gewinnst das Ding, du holst die drei Punkte und du kommst Stück für Stück da unten raus. Und ich muss bei Kiel immer so schmunzeln, ich habe die vor der Saison als Aufsteiger getippt, wenn irgendwer sich noch an dieses Tippspieler erinnert. Ich habe eine Statistik gesehen. Lieber nicht. Ich habe eine Statistik gesehen, schlecht ist der Bundesliga-Absteiger– seit 10 Jahren waren die –,Da dann auch erst mal wieder einen Turnaround zu schaffen und zu gucken, dass du nicht nur verlierst, verlierst und in so einer Negativspirale steckst. Das würde ich jetzt an der Stelle auch einfach mal positiv vermerken. Und wie man dann zu der ein oder anderen PK-Aussage steht, Schlitzohr ist, glaube ich, eine positive, nette Auslegung. Meine Attitude ist das jetzt persönlich auch nicht. Wenn es hilft, dass die gewinnen, dann würde ich als Holstein Kiel auch sagen, na ja, setz dich das nächste Mal gerne wieder so hin. Und Hauptsache, wir holen die Punkte. Weil das ist im Moment ja das Einzige, was zählt. So banal, wie es ja dann doch auch wieder klingt.
Ja, und ich glaube, ich sage jetzt was, was ich wirklich noch nie in diesem Podcast gesagt habe. Aber es war schon wichtig, einfach diese Negativspirale oder Negativserie zu stoppen, die man eben eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, seit Rückrundstart, dem 2-0-Sieg gegen Paderborn mal ausgenommen eben gefahren hat. Da hat man eben seit dem 23. oder seit dem 18.01. bis eben hin zu diesem 22.03., dem Sieg über den VfL Bochum, kein Spiel gewonnen und halt fast alle auch noch verloren. Bis auf das Unentschieden gegen Bielefeld und das Unentschieden gegen Elbersberg. Und das war, glaube ich, besprechend von Impulsen. Und das war dann vielleicht doch auch der richtige Impuls, auch wenn Tim Walther eben seine Zeit brauchte. Aber da muss man sagen, wenn wir eben bei Fortuna Düsseldorf darüber gesprochen haben, reicht die Zeit, muss man bei Kiel sagen, sie haben dann doch noch den richtigen Zeitpunktstand jetzt gefunden. Wie gesagt, der Mai wird halt, also ganz komischer Take, dass der Mai wichtig wird für Holstein Kiel, wie für ungefähr 20 andere Vereine in Fußballdeutschland, in den ersten beiden Ligen auch noch. Oder alleine, ich glaube, so 80 Prozent der 2. Liga. Von daher, ja, ist jetzt kein unfassbar hotter Hot-Take. Er ist eher sehr kalt, aber klar, das ist und es ist einfach so, das Wichtigste wird sein für diese letzten 5 Spiele. Und da kann man sagen, dass Hakela es mal geschafft, sich einfach in die richtige Position zu bringen. Ja, dass du einfach nicht komplett abgeschlagen bist, dass du ein okayes Torverhältnis noch hast. Und das haben sie eben, weil ich sage das gerne nochmal, das wird am Ende über sehr, sehr vieles entscheiden, weil einfach alles so eng da unten ist. Und auch oben ehrlich gesagt auch, darüber sprechen wir ja gleich auch noch. Gut, ich würde fast sagen, das Spiel beenden wir an der Stelle. Und Lisa, du hast es eben so schön gesagt, es war vielleicht spielerisch nicht der schönste der Kapitzen. Und ich finde, es gibt keine bessere Überleitung als dann zu diesem Spiel. Denn bei Münster gegen Fürth, ich möchte nicht sagen, man konnte diese dieser Partie über 90 Minuten wirklich anmerken. Es ist Tabellen 18. Tag gegen 17. Tag. Aber man konnte dieser Partie über 90 Minuten anmerken. Es ist 18. Tag gegen 17. Tag. Es findet am Ende kein Sieger. Dieses Spiel geht 0 zu 0 aus in einem Spiel, in dem Preußens zwar mehr Abschlüsse hat und führt mehr Ballbesitz, fehlt am Ende aber beiden Seiten das Tor. Und große Fußballweisheit, das braucht man, um drei Punkte im Abstiegskampf vor allem einzufahren. Und Anna, ich würde jetzt mal die These bringen, vor allem Preußens Münster bringt dieser Punkt wenig bis vielleicht sogar gar nichts.
Ja, ich fand es so phänomenal zu sehen, diese Abwägung zwischen Risiko zu verlieren oder dann mit leeren Händen da zu stehen und das rechtfertigen zu müssen versus einen Punkt, der ja wem genau hilft, in welchen Tabellenregionen, dass man den Abstand zu Kräuterwirt gewahrt hat. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Aber wir haben eben über Preußens Münster schon ansatzweise gesprochen, die ja diesen Trainerwechsel vorgenommen haben. Der alte Trainer ist jetzt in Düsseldorf untergekommen, der neue Trainer Alois Schwarz. Und ich glaube, Eva, du hattest du in der All-Star-WhatsApp-Gruppe gesagt, das ist doch mal ein Philosophieswitch. Weil ja, so die spielerischen Ansätze und all das Kreative und die ganzen Elemente mit dem Ball unter Alois Schwarz jetzt nicht ganz oben auf der Prioritätmiste stehen. Und vielleicht geht es tatsächlich auch darum. Also es ist eine relativ trister Statistik, wenn man sagt, unter Alois Schwarz konnte Preußen Münster noch kein einziges Tor schießen. Allerdings, was sicherlich den ein oder anderen Preußen-Fan freuen wird, sie haben auch in zwei Spielen kein einziges Gegentor gefangen. Und die Statistik hast du ja gerade vorgelesen, die Gegentor-Statistik der Münsteraner. Wahrscheinlich ist das auch das Fundament, auf dem da gerade der Funken Hoffnung gepflanzt wird. Dass man sagt, ja, das stimmt, wir konnten nicht gewinnen, aber wir haben wieder zu Null gespielt. Und vielleicht steht diese Null aktuell einfach tatsächlich über allem und ganz groß und sogar so groß, dass man dafür in Kauf nimmt, kein Tor gegen Fürth zu schießen. Das ist zumindest die Perspektive, aus der ich mir das so ein bisschen zurechtlege. Ja, weshalb das tatsächlich die Vorgabe war. Hauptsache Null. Wenn hinten die Null, dann erkaufen wir sie uns, meinetwegen auch mit vorne die Null.
Lisa, ergänzt gerne.
Ja, ich glaube, das macht total Sinn, was du sagst, Anna. Und ich würde das sogar noch ein Stück weit verstehen können, würde man in der Tabelle ein bisschen weiter oben stehen. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Punkt an der Stelle, ist auch wieder so eine Binsenweisheit. Aber wenn du halt Tabellenletzter bist und du bist im Moment zwei Punkte hinten dran, dann verstehe ich auf der einen Seite, dass man sagt, okay, lass irgendwie gucken, dass du dir nicht wieder 2, 3, 4, 5, es gab ja auch schon die eine oder andere richtig hohe Klatsche, fängst gerade nicht gegen den Abstiegskonkurrenten. Aber Null, Null, das hilft halt nicht. Also das hilft, führt noch mehr, auch wenn es denen auch nicht richtig hilft, als Münster, weil Münster halt wirklich ganz, ganz hinten drin steht. Und auch mit Blick auf das Restprogramm, ich glaube, das werden wir wahrscheinlich bei jedem noch so ein bisschen im Blick haben, finde ich ja ehrlicherweise, hat Münster so das größte Brett mit den nächsten fünf Spieltagen. Also ich habe hier Schalke, Hannover, Darmstadt, Elbersberg, Bielefeld. Ja, also da hätte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Mut, zumindest auch Kiel. Das war ja das Spiel die Woche vorher, das habe ich ehrlicherweise nicht gesehen. Ich saß aber in der Sport-Tour-Redaktion neben dem Kollegen, der den Spielbericht schreiben musste und der auch ganz viel Spaß hatte, sich dieses 0-0 anzugucken, wo ich halt auch sage, also ich verstehe auf der einen Seite den Gedanken, aber es hilft dir so wenig, dass man da eigentlich ein bisschen mehr vielleicht investieren muss, um auch auf das Tor zu gehen. Ja, seit Oktober kein Heimsieg ist ja eine Statistik, die ich auch noch mir ausgeschrieben hatte in der Vorbereitung. Das wird halt schwer. Also bei aller Liebe, ja, zweimal die Null hinten, die steht, aber puh, ich glaube nicht, dass das noch ein gutes Ende nimmt, wenn ich mich zu so einer ganz, ganz leichten Prognose hinreißen lassen müsste.
Ja, also zur Untermahnung vielleicht in ein paar Zahlen. Also erst mal Platz 18 ist es, 28 Punkte, 31 zu 47 Tore, ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, 6 Siege, 10 Unentschieden. Also diese Menge an Unentschieden, die ist schon relativ hoch und eben 13 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle sagt eben auch Platz 18, 3 Niederlagen, 2 Unentschieden. Man ist jetzt halt eben seit, zum dritten Spiel in Folge auf Platz 18. Die tiefste Platzierung in der Hinrunde war Platz 12 und seitdem ist man wirklich nur noch im unteren Drittel zu Hause. Und mein Problem ist, glaube ich, also gucken wir auf das Kiel-Spiel und auf dieses Fürth-Spiel. Man hatte kumuliert drei Schüsse aufs Tor. Und diese drei Schüsse aufs Tor kommen alle vom Spiel gegen Fürth. Also man hat mehr Torschüsse generell, aber wirklich die, also auch, glaube ich, nur eine Großchance im Endeffekt. Das reicht halt in dieser Phase nicht. So, und das ist auch hier meine Hauptproblematik, wo ich so ein bisschen sehe. Und das war, glaube ich, auch das, was von vielen, ich glaube auch von Münster-Fans zum Teil kritisiert wurde. Also es gibt auch einen längeren Kommentar dazu im Forum, dass eben so, ja, wo man nicht so wirklich weiß, also setzt man jetzt alles auf diese Heimspiele noch, wo wir eben wissen, da haben sie jetzt eben zuletzt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Punkte geholt. Lisa, du hast es gesagt. Also wenn wir generell mal auf die Tabelle schauen, da ist man heim, steht man eben auf Platz 15, auswärts auch auf Platz 15. Also ob das jetzt, du kannst doch nicht mal gerade eben sagen, ok, dann holst du da jetzt eben die Punkte, das ist eben schon ein Problem. Und ich weiß es nicht. Also, naja, auch, ich glaube, in dem Spiel führte fast 70 Prozent Ballbesitz. Gut, ich meine, wir reden gleich noch kurz über sie. Da eben auch dieser komplette Philosophiewechsel zu einer Mannschaft, die eben sehr, sehr viel Ballbesitz hatte, zu Beginn oder unter Alex Ende zu wenig. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das wirklich einfach zu groß war. Weil natürlich ist es gut, dass du, ja, du hast es super rausgearbeitet, aber es bringt dir halt nichts, wenn du dir vorne halt nichts mehr erarbeitest. So, weil Mauern bis zum 34. Spieltag wird dir halt absolut gar nichts bringen und einfach nur hoffen, dass da vorne einer reingeht, weil ich sehe trotzdem keinen, also, correct me if I'm wrong, aber ich sehe eben keinen offensiven Ansatz und das ist genau das, was Alois Schwarz am Ende auch immer seinen Job gekostet hat. So, ja, also, ich kenne keinen, der jetzt gesagt hat, wo Alois Schwarz in den letzten Jahren war oder Offensivfußball unter Alois Schwarz. Ja, wir haben aber Spaß gemacht. So, also, wie gesagt, ich finde das auch valide zu sagen, wir müssen die Gegend Torflut einstellen und alles, aber zu dieser Phase in der Saison, ich sage es gerne nochmal, super tolle Fußball-Weisheit, du brauchst halt Tore, dringend.
Ja, absolut. Also es ist kein guter Zeitpunkt, um den Sprint einzustellen. Das, ja, ist wild, irgendwie. Ich bin wirklich, wirklich gespannt, weil ich finde es einfach eine komplett krasse 180-Grad-Wendung zu einem komischen Zeitpunkt. Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Ganz egoistisch gibt es mir einfach ein bisschen Hoffnung für meinen eigenen Verein.
Komisch. Fair point. Ja, also ich weiß nicht. Ich meine, natürlich, klar, wenn du am Ende 0-0 gegen Schalke holst, sagt niemand, okay, schlecht. Aber auch da, also ähnliches, was ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, auch das bringt dir nichts in dieser Phase.
Hol das 0-0 erstmal und dann, wie du sagst, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt bei diesem Programm unbedingt ein 0-0 sehe. Das ist ja jetzt, also es geht ja für alle auch noch um ein bisschen was. Kommen wir ja auch gleich zu, Schalke, Hannover. Also pfuh, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Und das sind ja auch Mannschaften, die gerne Tore schießen und die auch Tore schießen können, also ja, schwierig. Also glaube ich schon schlechte Konstellation an der Stelle für Münster.
Ja und dann muss man eben sagen, man hat eben auch gegen zwei Vereine gespielt, die jetzt auch nicht von Offensiv-A, weiß ich nicht, Kraft nur so strotzen. Also wie viel Aussagekraft hat dann die Null, die hinten steht? Das ist für mich dann halt die Frage. Also ich würde mir– klar, es kommt als Bielefeld-Fan immer so ein bisschen komisch– aber ich würde mir aus Preußensicht große Sorgen wirklich um dieses Endprogramm machen. Und auch das, was eben in diesem Vorungsbeitrag durchschwang, klang jetzt nicht sonderlich. Also ich habe echt so das Gefühl, die Euphorie, die ist auch irgendwie weg. Du merkst das, wie ich finde, was so durchkommt im Stadion zum Teil. Also ich meine, vielleicht ist es ein Vorteil, dass es eben noch eine Derby gibt in diesem Endspurt. Ja, weil wir wissen alle, das kann vieles freisetzen so. Aber ob das reicht, da würde ich erst mal daran zweifeln. Vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Aber ich würde fast sagen, dann leiten wir mal über zu einem anderen Part dieses wundervollen Spiels. Das ist ein Spiel, was übrigens unserem lieben Kollegen Michael Fischer dazu– er hat nur beschrieben, es ging vorher darum, dass es endlich Netto-Spielzeiten eingeführt werden sollten. Und dann hat er nur dazu geschrieben, zum Glück gab es die in diesem Spiel nicht, sonst wäre das sein letztes Fußballspiel gewesen. Also Kraft an Michael Fischer an der Stelle nochmal, dass er sich das 90 Minuten angucken musste. Für die Spielvereinigung führt das eben Platz 17, 30 Punkte, 40 zu 61 Tore, 8 Siege, 6 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle Platz 13, 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen. Nach dieser guten Phase, Mitte Februar bis Mitte März, gab es jetzt 3 Spiele ohne Sieg. Und man muss sagen, in der denkbar schlechtesten Phase in der Saison. Im Spiel gegen Münster kann man sich vor allem, ehrlich gesagt, noch bei Silos Prüfrock bedanken. Sonst war das sehr dünn. Man sieht vor allem den Ausfall von Dennis Rebeni, auch Marco Ion, der gerade erst wieder zwei Spiele zur Verfügung stand, hat sich im Spiel gegen Münster verletzt. Anbruch des Wadenbeinköpfchen bei Noel Futtgold, rot eine Sperre wegen fünfter gelber Karte. Also auch da sieht es jetzt in der Offensive gar nicht mal so rosig aus. Ich sage, so ein bisschen die Spielvereinigung führt. Sie ist für mich im Abstiegskampf so ein bisschen dieses Gänseblümchen. Also mal schafft es, mal schafft es nicht. Zwischendurch war diese Pflanze einmal komplett tot. Ja, und dann kam sie wieder raus, so ein bisschen den Frühling anvisiert. Aber, Lisa, ich weiß immer, ich putte dich an den Spot, so als Clubfan. Aber was machen wir denn mit der Spielvereinigung?
Ja, was machen wir denn? Also ich sage mal so, es kommt ja noch ein Derby. Das haben wir ja gerade auch schon beim Blick auf Münster erwähnt. Da bin ich auch sehr, sehr gespannt drauf. Also ganz verstehe ich ehrlicherweise führt diese Saison nicht. Du hast den positiven Zwischensprint ja gerade schon so ein bisschen angerissen. Also wenn ich jetzt gerade hier Fürth gegen Münster mir angucke, dann frage ich mich schon so, wie haben die 2-1 gegen Hannover gewonnen? Wie haben die einen Punkt gegen Schalke gemacht? Das ist schon, also es für mich irgendwie zeigt, wie absurd diese Liga ein Stück weit ist. Ja, also so richtig viel Hoffnung. Also ja, ich will es gar nicht sagen, so richtig viel Hoffnung, sich befürchtet ehrlicherweise an vielen Stellen auch nicht. Mit Blick auf Stressprogramme dann deutlich mehr als bei Münster. Das sage ich schon, aber die Statistiken, du hast ja gerade schon ein bisschen was aufgezählt. Wenigste Torschüsse, wenigste Flanken aus dem Spiel, wenigste intensive Läufe. Ich gucke mir das immer gerne noch mal so ein bisschen an, bevor ich hier reinkomme, weil es ja ein ganz gutes Gefühl auch gibt, so wo steht eine Mannschaft und wenn selbst der Trainer, das fand ich irgendwie sehr bezeichnend, was Heikenvogel so nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, naja, ich habe gemerkt, wir können hier nicht gewinnen, naja, dann muss ich halt schauen, dass ich nicht verliere. Ja, das tut mir fast schon weh, auch wenn ich weiß, man will ja kein Mitleid von Clubseite haben, aber ich hoffe sehr, dass Föhrt es noch schafft, weil persönlich fände ich es total schade, wenn es kein Döring mehr gäbe. Ich glaube, das versteht auch jeder Fan an der Stelle, weil es doch immer ein Highlight ist und irgendwie dazugehört und das schon, also es würde einfach sehr, sehr fehlen an der Stelle, gerade wenn man in der 2. Liga spielt und es nicht damit begründet ist, dass der Club aufsteigt, was ja jetzt auch nicht so in Abseemacher Zukunft passiert. Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen ratlos an der einen oder anderen Stelle, muss ich gestehen, wenn ich so bei Föhrt bin. Also ich habe hier Restprogramm gerade noch mal drauf geschielt. Darmstand, ja, wird auch nicht so einfach werden. Aber Bochum, Nürnberg, Hertha Düsseldorf. Ja, also es ist nicht aussichtlos. Es ist nicht Hertha und Lauten, das war doch eine Sache.
Hertha und Lauten, die haben noch richtig Aktien trotzdem im Auf-
und Abschiedskampf. Ja, und für beide gibt es nicht mehr so richtig viel. Also ich bin jetzt nicht hoffnungslos, wenn ich auf Föhrt blicke. Aber es wird schon schwer, um es vielleicht so zu formulieren. Ich meine, vielleicht reißen sie das Ruder rum und es kommt der nächste Zwischensprint. Vielleicht ist es auch ein– ich will es gar nicht sagen– vielleicht ist es auch ein Derbysieg, der dann irgendwie noch mal einen positiven Push gibt. Das würde ich mir natürlich nicht wünschen. Aber ja, also ich finde, das ist für mich eine ganz komische Saison an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Verstehe ich auch immer noch nur bedingt.
Annalisa hat gerade schon so ein paar Zitate genannt. Ich werfe dir noch mal zwei Sätze vor. Also Vogel hat eben auch auf der Pressekonferenz gesagt, ich bin nicht zufrieden mit dem Spiel. Ich bin aber zufrieden mit dem Punkt, den wir dann mitnehmen. Und sagt dann auch, wir haben es heute nicht verdient, mit drei Punkten nach Hause zu fahren, weil wir uns suboptimal verhalten haben. Was macht man mit solchen Aussagen?
Ja, unser Trainer, kleine Fußnote, hat in der Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel gegen Bochum gesagt, wir waren zu Tor ungefährlich. Fühlst du das? Das fand ich irgendwie auch. Also, ja, kann man vielleicht da ganz passend zu assoziieren. Irgendwie kann ich das logisch nachvollziehen, dieses, ich bin unzufrieden mit dem Spiel, deswegen bin ich zufrieden mit dem Punkt. Das ja irgendwie erst mal passt das ganz gut zusammen. Ich erinnere mich halt im Kontext Fürth in dieser Saison wirklich an schreckliche Zusammenbrüche defensiver Natur. Also unglaubliche, ja, unsortierteheiten, gerade so im defensiven Verbund, bei denen ich ehrlich gesagt verwundert bin, dass der Trainer das überhaupt noch sortieren konnte. Also ich finde, die Situation, in der Fürth steht, ist tatsächlich insgesamt, würde ich sagen, eher Erfolg als Misserfolg, weil ich das zwischen, also ich finde nicht, dass man das halt kommen sehen, dass Fürth dann noch mal so mitmischen würde, tatsächlich im Abstiegskampf, weil ich vor dieser, ihr habt das gerade Gute Phase genannt, vor dieser guten Phase gedacht habe, die sind einfach weg. Gerade, weil diese gute Phase ja auf Spiele fiel, in denen man nicht denkt, dass ein Abstiegskandidat da groß was holen würde. Also das ist zum einen dieses 2-1 auswärts in Hannover, aber dann schlagen sie auch Elbersberg 2 zu 0. Und das hatte ich tatsächlich, also wirklich exakt überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel. Und meine These da ist, dass die 2. Liga vor allem dann einen neuen Dreh bekommt, wenn Mannschaften wie viert in einer, wie damals Situation auf Mannschaften treffen, die denken, das wird schon. Weil, also es ist ein Effekt von dem, von dem die Braunschweiger Eintracht massiv profitiert. Wir haben auch im Winter dann 2-0 gegen Schalke gewonnen. Weil ich schon glaube, dass das vielleicht auch Effekte sind, gegen die sich dann ein sogenannter Favorit auch gar nicht immer wehren kann, weil du ja die Zahlen siehst und irgendwie denkst, naja gut, dies und das, das große Ziel vor Augen. Und wird es da irgendwie nur so eine kleine Zwischenstation, das kriegen wir schon hin. Und ich glaube, dass dafür aber auch abgeschlagene Mannschaften in der 2. Liga zu gut sind, um sich die Chance dann entgehen zu lassen. Das wäre eben meine Arbeitshypothese zu dieser guten Phase. Die aber offenbar nicht gleichbedeutend mit einer konstanten Leistungssteigerung des gesamten Teams einhergeht. Weil es ja auch manchmal so ist, du hast diese Erfolgserlebnisse, also gewinnst du spielerische Sicherheit, also werden deine Spiele sukzessive besser. Dieser Effekt scheint in 4. nicht eingetreten zu sein. Und eine Prognose ist sehr schwierig, finde ich. Also ich sehe nicht, dass die noch mal daran anknüpfen, was sie zwischenzeitlich gezeigt haben. Nehme aber den Trainer als so stoisch war. Ich übe mich hier heute in positiven Wörtern für Dinge, die man vielleicht auch anders formulieren könnte. Und ich glaube, die Nervenstärke von Heiko Vogel und sein Hang und vielleicht Nervosität nicht eins zu eins nach außen zu transportieren, könnte ein Vorteil werden der Spielvereinigung.
Ja, also was ich glaube, ich befürchte auch immer noch sagen muss, du hast eben angesprochen, man hat das Gefühl, das überträgt sich nicht so richtig auf die Spieler. Also ich glaube schon wirklich, dass diese Auswahl von Srebreni vielleicht wirklich saisonentscheidend gewesen sein kann, wie böse das auch klingt. Ja, ich muss halt sagen, also alle Spieler, die sonst bei Führer vielleicht individuell immer wieder gezeigt haben, was sie reinbringen können. Klaus war komplett unsichtbar, Furtkoi hat nicht wirklich was gezeigt. Also wirklich, Sielas Prüfrock ist so noch der heimliche Held, der natürlich auch wirklich immer so ein bisschen die ärmste Sau war, muss man ja fast sagen. Der aber, wie ich finde, einer der Spieler ist, die sich schon so im Laufe, also gefühlt ist er für mich der Einzige, der sich schon weiterentwickelt hat, auch mit dieser positiven Phase. Ich meine, klar, es ist bitter, du wechselst in der 63. Minute Jone aus, äh, ein, und in der 78. musst du ihn eben verletzungsbedingt wieder auswechseln. Dafür kommt dann übrigens Julian Green, finde ich auch ganz interessant. Also ich glaube, wir brauchen nicht darüber diskutieren, dass einfach dieser Kader weiterhin ein Problem bleibt, obwohl ich weiterhin der Meinung bin, dass du da eigentlich mehr rausholen hättest können. Aber ja, also ich meine, ich muss sowieso sagen, wenn ich auf dieses Spiel gucke, ich verstehe noch, okay, Münster wechselt insgesamt nur dreimal in dieser Partie, obwohl sie noch einen Meier Höfer und einen Batista Meier offer, also bis vor allem einen Batista Meier offer Bank haben, okay, vielleicht wolltest du da nichts riskieren, checke. Aber wenn du in deinem Spiel siehst, dass du eigentlich die bessere Mannschaft bist und von Fürth kommt nichts gleichzeitig führt, da konntest du eben noch nicht mit der ersten Halbzeit zufrieden sein. Dass er dann erst so spät wechselt und so spät eingreift in die Partie, fand ich dann auch schon bemerkenswert, ehrlich gesagt, aus Trainer-Sicht. Weil ich hatte dann auch irgendwann das Gefühl, er ist mir eine Spur im Spiel schon zu zufrieden mit dem 0-0. Und das, also er wechselt dann ja eigentlich auch, bis auf Arifi für Klaus, gefühlt nur defensiv. Also er nimmt Dietz raus, er nimmt Reich raus. Ja gut, dann muss er eben nochmal verlässungsbedingt, dass er ein guter Teil ist, die andere Seite. Also aber, ja, habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz verstanden, sowieso dann natürlich aber auch die Empfehlung. Mehr die tiefere Analyse zu diesem wunderbaren Spiel, hört ihr natürlich gerne eben für der Flachbass nach. Da werden, glaube ich, vielleicht werden da Fragen beantwortet, die wir hier jetzt gestellt haben. Ich kann sie auf jeden Fall nicht beantworten. Ich dachte also dafür, dass ich bei Führtschammer einmal dachte, sie wären irgendwie auf einem richtig guten Weg, verstehe ich nicht. Wie gesagt, sie sind für mich das Gänseblümchen der Liga. So ein bisschen positiv gesehen. Don't know, ob man das so sagen kann, aber gut. Bevor wir den Abstiegskampf verlassen, habe ich noch ein paar Ankündigungen zu machen. Anna und Lisa dürfen kurz eine Minute durchschnauben und durchatmen. Zunächst einmal danke natürlich für das Feedback zur letzten Folge und generell für euren Input natürlich immer auch zu dieser Folge, aber generell immer zwischendurch aus. Das leitet mich aber zu einem kleinen Punkt über zu der Forumsdiskussion, die es eben vor allem im Nachgang zu dem Hertha-Dresden-Spiel gab. Ich habe das eben schon mal angekündigt, per se. Ich freue mich darüber, dass ihr diskutiert und dass ihr diesen Input-Thread so gut nutzt. Allerdings sage ich das hier jetzt einfach nochmal. Es ist halt gerade, weil wir eben nicht wie bei der Bundesliga der Männer oder so wirklich Spieltagsendungen haben, sondern einen gesammelten Thread. Weiß ich, dass das schwierig ist, manchmal dann halt wirklich beim Sportlichen zu bleiben, aber per se ist es einfach für mich, vielleicht als Moderatorin, aber vielleicht auch für andere Forum-Userinnen, ein bisschen schwierig, wenn dann eine lange Diskussion über Pyrotechnik und Choreos und so beginnt. Und ihr könnt gerne über alles diskutieren, was ihr wollt, bitte, aber auch immer, da schließe ich mich Max an, in einem Rahmen, die wirklich Diskussionskultur fördernd ist und nicht ich bin übrigens der Meinung und niemand kann die ändern. Das bringt uns in einer Diskussion nichts und ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich ein bisschen bestätigt darin gefühlt, wie dieser Threat, ich habe da quergelesen zum Hertha-Dresden-Spiel, dann weitergeführt wurde. Das hatte halt irgendwann noch nicht mal mehr was mit diesem Spiel zu tun, obwohl so der Threat ist. Es gibt einen Threat zu Pyrotechnik, es gab einen Threat dazu und da wurden hinter Sachen diskutiert, wo ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, weiß ich nicht so ganz, ob das wirklich auch Ziel bringt für so eine Community ist, wenn man da so drüber diskutiert. Dann gab es einen Punkt dazu, dass im Rasenfunk wohl immer negativ über die Polizei gesprochen wird und jetzt das gar nicht lohnend erwähnt wird oder ähnliches. Dazu sei gesagt, ja ich weiß, das gebe ich auch gerne zu, ich bin, da ich in erster Linie Fußballfan bin und sehr viel fahre und sehr viele Fußballspiele besuche und dadurch sehr viel Kontakt zu der Polizei tatsächlich auch habe, sicherlich kann ich da nicht ganz unbeteiligt auf die Sache blicken. Ich bin weiterhin aber auch der Meinung, man darf der Polizei durchaus die anders bewerten, als man Fußballfans bewertet, weil wir sprechen hier von einem Staatsorgan und von Fußballfans. Dass beide Seiten Treize bauen, können wir uns glaube ich schon einig sein, aber so viel noch dazu. Und genau, sowieso bitte seid freundlich zueinander, bitte geht einander nicht an. Ich mache Fehler, andere machen Fehler. Genau, und wenn ihr sowieso schon wisst oder meint zu wissen, wie meine Meinung zu etwas aussieht, warum wollt ihr dann unbedingt, dass ich was dazu sage? Das ist für mich dann irgendwie nicht so ganz logisch. Sorry, das war ein sehr langer Feedback-Teil. Trotzdem natürlich per se könnt ihr wirklich über alles diskutieren. Es ist natürlich muss am Ende das sowieso Max entscheiden, nicht ich. Das war nur der eine Punkt, wo ich dann interagiert habe. Es ist vielleicht manchmal auch schwierig, sowas immer alles nur digital zu machen und nicht die Personen vor sich zu haben. Generell liebe ich aber die Rasenfunk-Community, liebe den Discord, liebe euch Kommentierende da draußen und freue mich immer über Feedback. Und natürlich an der Stelle die Erinnerung, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren euch uns ausschließlich durch eure Unterstützung. Mehr Infos gibt es dazu unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da könnt ihr, falls ihr es noch nicht seid, SupporterInnen werden oder vielleicht sogar euren Beitrag noch ein bisschen hochschalten, wenn ihr nämlich vor allem gesehen hat, was vor allem Max ja in den letzten Wochen hier rausgehauen hat, an Tribünen gesprochen und Co und was alles noch so kommt. Und es ist Royalzeit, geht wieder los. Also wenn ihr sagt, das Auto lasse ich momentan stehen, die, weiß ich nicht, 50 Euro für eine halbe Dankladung, die investiere ich lieber in den Rasenfunk, dann go for it. Sonst wisst ihr, es ist gestern oder in der Nacht zu heute, wir haben jetzt Montagabend, ist die Besprechung des Bundesligaspieltags der Männer entschieden. Logischerweise gibt es kein Äquivalent zur Bundesliga der Frauen, denn morgen und Samstag stehen die Spiele, Länderspiele gegen Österreich an. Dazu erscheint dann in der Nacht auf Sonntag eine Folge. Gegebenenfalls gibt es noch einen Schwerpunkt bei den Männern, aber die Royalezeit steht an und die Frage ist, wie viel mehr das gerade noch bringt. Monolog Eva, Part 2, Ende. Dann können wir uns nämlich von unten nach oben schauen und wir gucken auf das Spiel Elbersberg gegen Schalke 04. Letztere gewinnen das direkte Duell gegen Elbersberg mit 2 zu 1. Dabei geht die SVE schon nach 4 Minuten durch Schnellwache in Führung. Wortwitze, let's go. Allerdings kann El Fawzi in der 48. Minute den Ausgleich erzielen, bei der Schalke aufgrund einer Verletzung von Elbersbergs Keidel in Überzahl ist. Kurz nach Wiederantritt sind ein Die nach einem vermeintlichen faulen Petkoff, die gelb-rote Karte, die hinterher für viele Diskussionen sorgen wird. Schalke kann dennoch 2 Minuten später durch Silla in Führung gehen und bleibt danach defensiv stabil. Elbersberg kann den Ausgleich nicht mehr passieren und muss eben so einen kleinen Dämpfer im Ausstiegskampf hinnehmen. Am Montag wird übrigens dann noch klar, Schalke hat mit seinem Einspruch, Erfolg nie da ist Sperre, wird zurückgenommen. Anna, lass uns zuerst auf die SVE schauen. Platz 4 ist es momentan, 52 Punkte. Wir bewegen uns in andere Tabellenregionen, 49 zu 32 Tore, 15 Siege, 7 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Vom Tabelle ist allerdings nur Platz 11 momentan, sowie viele andere Teams, 2 Sieger, 1 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlage. Nach dem Sieg gegen Bielefeld vor der Länderspielpause folgte jetzt noch ein Unentschieden gegen Hannover und eben die Niederlage gegen Schalke. Würdest du mir zustimmen, dass es vielleicht ein Spiel war, wo am Ende Schalkes Effizienz liegt? Also vielleicht genau die Effizienz, die in der Partie gegen Hannover Elbersberg auch schon gefehlt hat?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja. Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht durch dieses, ich finde, Nachlassen ist eigentlich ein zu starkes Wort, weil ich nicht den Eindruck habe, dass das unbedingt zu der Intensität der Spiele passt, die Elbersberg abliefert, die ich super hoch finde. Das sind immer unglaublich konzentrierte Leistungen. Ich finde, dass ein sehr intensives Coaching, das da stattfindet, ohne dass das irgendwie diesen Fokus auf sich zieht, den ich manchmal bei Kohfeldt habe, wo ich finde, dass er da wirklich sehr präsent ist. Es fällt mir gerade schwer, in Worte zu fassen. Ich finde das eigentlich alles sehr gradlinig auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite. Flauen gerade die Ergebnisse ab und sie sind jetzt noch ein Stück davon entfernt, den Anschluss an die Spitze zu verlieren. Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich in der Saison hätte ich einiges darauf gesetzt, dass die sich da oben so richtig dörflich festsetzen, weil sie sich von keinem reinquatschen lassen, weil sie keine krasse Presse haben, weil sie ein viel ruhigeres Umfeld haben als Schalke oder Hannover, dass die einfach ihr Ding durchziehen und dann als erster oder zweiter souverän aufsteigen. Und dieses, finde ich schon gerade, vielleicht irgendwie Delle oder kleines Low, überrascht mich ein bisschen, weil das irgendwie auch relativ lautlos passiert. Und aus dem werde ich nicht so richtig schlau. Vielleicht ist es mit fehlender Effizienz, wie du das gerade gesagt hast, tatsächlich ganz gut beschrieben auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. Wenn ich mich jetzt auch gegen, also in dem Spiel gegen 96 würde ich sagen, trifft das auf jeden Fall, nee, trifft das tatsächlich eher nicht so zu, weil Hannover super spielstark gewesen ist. Elbersberg kriegt einen Elfmeter eher geschenkt als verdient zugesprochen, verwandelt den und fährt dann mit einem verhältnismäßig glücklichen 1-1 nach Hause. Jetzt gegen Schalke, vielleicht war das einfach wirklich, denn doch diese eine Nummer zu groß als Gegner. Also ich glaube, dass Schalke total gebrannt hat. Also mit vielen Verletzungen, Sperren etc., sprechen wir gleich noch in Ruhe drüber, hatte ich das Gefühl, dass die sich vorgenommen haben, uns spuckt hier keiner in die Suppe und wir ziehen das hier eiskalt durch. Und dass das irgendwie ein Level von Konzentriertheit war, das in der Liga wahrscheinlich tatsächlich seinesgleichen sucht und Ebersberg jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an seine oberen Grenzen stößt in den letzten beiden Spielen in Hannover mit dieser titzhaften Sortiertheit. Und Schalke jetzt zu Hause. Vielleicht ist es doch dieser Aufstieg noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Also um es ein bisschen perspektivisch zu setzen, man muss dazu sagen, dass ähnliche Punkteausbeute bzw. genau die gleiche Punkteausbeute gab es in der Hinrunde eben auch. Also da gab es eben auch eine Niederlage gegen Schalke, eine Knappe, ein 2 zu 2 gegen Hannover. Also per se, da kann man jetzt vielleicht davon reden, okay, vielleicht fehlte da so ein bisschen Anführungsstrichen die Weiterentwicklung oder man kann einfach sagen, gut, sie können halt trotzdem mithalten mit diesen Teams, die ja doch auf dem Platz dann ganz, ganz andere Qualitäten mitbringen. Also ich fand, ich würde dir so ein bisschen fast sogar in der, beim Hannover-Spiel vielleicht in Teilen widersprechen. Also ich fand das, ja da fast, also Hannover hatte den spielerisch besseren Ansatz, aber ich fand Elversberg trotzdem nicht chancenlos. Also sie machen am Ende nur das Tor durch den Elfmeter und da gehe ich auch mit, der war durchaus schmeichelhaft. Ich fand das trotzdem aber, also mein Problem ist glaube ich eher so, ihnen ist so ein bisschen das, was sie im Spiel gegen Bielefeld zum Beispiel noch hatten, diese offensive Leichtigkeit abhandgekommen. Also sie waren ja über lange Zeit eigentlich auch das offensiv stärkste Team der Liga. Da habe ich eher so das Gefühl, dass es ihnen so ein bisschen abhanden gekommen. Diese Spielfreude auch eigentlich, also wie gesagt, gut gegen Bielefeld hast du eigentlich gesehen, was sie für eine Wucht entwickeln können, wenn sie führen. Und das hat mir hier bei dem 1-0 so ein bisschen gefehlt. Natürlich muss man da aber auch trotzdem mal mit reinrechnen, wir reden gleich noch über Schalke. Es ist wirklich brutal schwer diesen, das haben sie schon beim 1-0 sehr, sehr schön. Also ich finde das sehr schön rausgespielt, das 1-0 mit Schnellbach hat dann am Ende, der vollendet. Aber das ist mir irgendwann so ein bisschen abhanden gekommen, glaube ich, in dem Spiel. Sonst muss man sagen, es wird, glaube ich, also da schon mal nach vorne zu blicken. Du hast jetzt eben noch die direkten Duelle gegen Darmstadt und Paderborn. Empfängst du jetzt erst, glaube ich, zu Hause Karlsruhe und dann eben auswärts bei Darmstadt und zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Also ich glaube, da reicht es halt nicht, dass du, also beziehungsweise gegen Paderborn hast du gewonnen in der Hinrunde gegen Darmstadt unentschieden gespielt. Da bleibt dann halt so ein bisschen die Frage, wie gehen diese Partien aus? Surprise. Ob du es da dann halt schaffst, vielleicht die so ein bisschen auf deine Spielweise zu ziehen. Also auf das, was du eigentlich willst. Das heißt, also ich verstehe schon, was du mit Delle meinst. Wie gesagt, das sieht jetzt halt gerade einfach nicht so gut aus. Du hast halt 6 zu 6 Tore, 2 Sieger in unentschieden zwei Niederlagen. Das ist irgendwie so ein Hühn-Hot auch gerade. Also dir fehlt so ein bisschen die Konstanz drin. Und ich glaube, das ist eher das größere Problem, dass du dir das halt, wenn du aufsteigen willst, gar nicht erlauben kannst. Gleichzeitig sage ich es auch gerne nochmal. Da ist dann immer die Frage, ist der mangelnde Druck gut oder ist der mangelnde Druck schlecht? Und ich glaube, man muss da auch ganz, ganz wichtig sagen, viel größer wird ja sowieso die Frage sein, wie geht der Elwasberger Weg weiter? Denn wir wissen alle, Ole Boke ist mit sofortiger Wirkung zu Borussia Dortmund gewechselt, Christian Weber ist der neue Sportdirektor, ehemals bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Da bleibt für mich tatsächlich auf lange Perspektive eher die Frage, also wir haben uns alle, ich sage es zum hunderttausendsten Mal, wie damals gefragt, wie werden sie Horst Steffen überleben und so wie Elvesbergs Konzept ist, mit natürlich auch viel mit Leihspielern arbeiten und darüber ein Konzept entwickeln, über die Art und Weise, was man für einen Fußball spielen lassen will. Das hängt dann natürlich in Zukunft auch sehr davon ab, wer eben auf diesem Sportdirektor posten sitzt, wir wissen jetzt, wer das ist. Aber, ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht. Dass man da jetzt nicht das große Risiko gibt, verstehe ich auch. Aber erstmal fand ich, in Anführungszeichen, das ein leichtes Downgrade im Vergleich zu Olebrook. Leichtes, ja? Ja, keine bösen Kommentare, aber.
Ja, aber ich finde es schwierig zu bewerten. Also gerade wenn ich jetzt an Düsseldorf zurückdenke, ich meine, über die haben wir ja schon ein bisschen gesprochen. Und wenn wir jetzt schauen, was bei Düsseldorf so passiert ist und was zum Beispiel da die Anspruchshaltung war, mit der man in diese Saison ist und auch diesen großen Umbruch. Klaus Alofs und Weber zusammen, so keiner mehr da jetzt. Das ist ja auch irgendwie bezeichnet, dass das halt gar nicht so funktioniert hat. Ja, bin ich gespannt, wie das jetzt matcht an der Stelle. Und gleichzeitig ist Elbersberg so ein Verein, der mich immer wieder total überrascht. Also ich hätte vor dieser Saison im Leben nicht drauf gewettet, dass die so oben mitspielen und dass das so... Also hätte ich im Leben nicht gedacht, also was da ja alles passiert ist, was da auch alles an Veränderungen, an Abgängen zu verkaufen, weil ich mein Haussteffner, das ist auch gerade schon erwähnt, aber das finde ich total schwierig zu bewerten. Also das ist für mich so ein bisschen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen eine Wundertüte, aber Elbersberg habe ich schon so oft falsch eingeschätzt. Wir alle. Ja, da bin ich wirklich so... Wir alle. Ich habe gar keine Ahnung von nix. So, das denke ich immer wieder bei Elbersberg. Auch, um vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen konkreter auf das Beispiel jetzt gegen Schalke zu gehen, die ersten Minuten war ich total geplättet, wie Elbersberg da aufgetreten ist im positiven Sinne. Auch, wie schnell das 1-0 fiel. Und was das für ein Gesicht war, dass die das nicht so durchziehen konnten und dass das nicht geklappt hat, das würde ich gar nicht so sehr auf... Elbersberg war irgendwie zu schwach und also diese Delle, sondern da kam halt gerade Schalke und auf welcher Welle die irgendwie gerade reiten. So habe ich das Gefühl, da kann gar nichts passieren und die haut nix um. Dass ich das Gefühl habe, das lag gar nicht so sehr an Elbersberg, sondern viel mehr an Schalke. Deswegen jetzt die letzten Spiele, klar, das Restprogramm, du hast das gerade angeteased, geht auch noch gegen direkte Konkurrenten und wird irgendwie spannend. Aber ich traue mir nicht so eine richtige Bewertung jetzt zu, auch was jetzt diese neue Stelle angeht.
Anna?
Ich finde es cool, dass die so Bock haben und dass auch danach formuliert wird, wie genervt die sind über die Niederlage gegen Schalke, dass die da schon sich was anderes vorgenommen hatten. Und das finde ich cool, dass du da aus einer enorm sportlichen Qualität, die du wirklich auf eine überhaupt nicht selbstverständliche Art und Weise jetzt in der zweiten Saison auf so konstant hohem Niveau hältst und ja auch nicht, wie es eigentlich oft typisch ist in der 2. Liga, durch so Phasen-Amplituden gehst. Dass du sagst, boah krass, vier Niederlagen, aber dafür auch wieder fünf Siege, sondern dass du eigentlich wirklich da einfach oben bleibst ohne große Ausschläge nach oben oder unten, trotz dieser großen Veränderungen, die du personell verkraften musstest. Zum einen, aber ja auch mental verkraftet nicht jedes Team eine Pleite in der Relegation so easy, da oben wieder anzugriffen. Auch Düsseldorf ist es irgendwie dann langfristig nicht besonders gut bekommen beispielsweise. Und jetzt wollte ich jetzt mal ich den Faden so ein bisschen verloren. Ach ja, genau. Wir haben eben in einem anderen Kontext, genau KSC haben wir darüber gesprochen, was ist da eigentlich die Idee. Und ich habe bei Elversberg das Gefühl, dass die Idee total klar ist. Also zum einen eben dieses Leihspieler-Konzept und auch darauf wirklich zu setzen. Und das finde ich, finde ich phänomenal und etwas, was glaube ich außerhalb eines solchen Standorts nur schwer zu vermitteln ist, aber eine hohe sportliche Qualität ganz offenbar mit sich trägt. Weil ja andere Vereine sagen, nein, wir möchten nicht nur mit Leihspielern arbeiten. Die sollen vielleicht punktuell Qualität dazu bringen, von der wir dann phasenweise profitieren. Aber wir möchten eigentlich im Grundsatz unseren Kader, unseren Spieler, unsere Identität, denn wir sind immer die Coolsten und wir brauchen Treue und wir brauchen Loyalität und so weiter. Also diese ganzen großen moral aufgeladenen Worte. Und das irgendwie umzukehren und zu sagen, unser Konzept ist die Anleihe von so hoher Qualität und die wird einfach immer wieder ausgetauscht. Worin das mündet, finde ich total– also weiß ich nicht genau, vielleicht weiß das eine von euch, ob das Sprungbrett ist dahin, dass du eben so wie Hoffenheim dann irgendwann deinen eigenen Kader hast, um Bundesliga zu spielen oder ob das einfach nachhaltige Strategie ist. Weil ich mir das zum Beispiel als sportliche Idee für die Kaderzusammenstellung jetzt in Braunschweig zum Beispiel nicht vorstellen kann. Das könntest du kommunikativ schlecht aufrechterhalten. These.
Ja, die Frage ist dann natürlich, glaube ich, schon immer. Elversberg kommt halt im Gegensatz, ich glaube vor allem zu unserem Verein, aber auch zu deinem Verein, Lisa, nicht aus so einer finanziellen Notwendigkeit her, dass die Spieler, die Jungspieler, die du weiterentwickelst, für Geld verkaufen musst. Also ich glaube, du kriegst es schon an vielen Standorten vermittelt, dass du dir davon eben deine finanzielle Stabilität erarbeiten musst, aber du bekommst es eben nicht an vielen Standorten vermittelt, dass du ja per se, also außer es ist beispielsweise bei Ebno Talib, wo du das ja schon auch finanziell gemerkt hast dann, dass es per se natürlich nicht funktioniert, dass du irgendwie als Talent weiterentwickeln giltst. Das glaube ich schon, das darf man da nicht so komplett. Also natürlich ist am Ende auch die SV Elversberg in einer Weise ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen, die Profit abwerfen will in irgendeiner Art und Weise, das ist mir auch schon bewusst, aber es kommt natürlich immer, woher kommst du finanziell und das ist eben was, wo wir natürlich bei unseren drei Vereinen beispielsweise sehen, da hast du jetzt nicht so die Freiheiten, dass du dir jetzt mal sagen kannst. Also ich glaube schon, dass man das dann nicht ganz unbeachtet sehen kann. Daher ist ja eben meine Frage, ob Christian Weber das so fortsetzt. Also er hat ja relativ kurz Vita bisher, er war Scout bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und dann eben drei Jahre bis zum 15. und 12. Sportdirektor. Es ist natürlich jetzt anders, weil er eben keinen Klaus-Alofs über sich sitzen hat. Also er hat schon eine andere Machtposition, in Anführungszeichen. Also er hat einfach eine andere Verantwortung. Das war halt so der Punkt, wo ich gesagt habe, ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus, dass er das alles auf links umkrempelt. Das wird Elversberg nicht wollen. Aber da bin ich eben sehr, sehr gespannt, ob sie das schaffen, diesen Weg eben fortzusetzen mit dieser Idee im Hinterkopf, mit der Identität, ob das alles so klappt. Würde ich fast sagen, die gleichen Fragen stellt sich der eine oder andere Elversberger, die Elversbergerin auch. Also das ist eben meine Frage. Aber das werden wir sowieso im Sommer alles sehen. Ich gehe auch davon aus, die größten Stellschrauben, die hat Ole Burk sowieso schon gestellt für die kommende Saison. Auch wenn es natürlich schwierig ist, wenn du noch nicht weißt, in welcher Liga du spielst. Aber ich gehe fast davon aus, dass es da schon so ein paar Stellschrauben einfach gibt, die er dir auch anzupfen kann. Und man muss eben sagen, Christian Biber war eben auch vorher Scout. Er bringt natürlich auch so ein bisschen diesen, ich sag mal, erstmal vielleicht mehr operativen Teil noch mit, den du als Sportdirektor eben auch brauchst. Aber es ist sowieso, wie gesagt, es ist alle Spekulation. Ich gehe aber sonst auch mit euren Beobachtungen mit. Wie gesagt, ich finde, sonst kann man sich Elbersbergspiel auch sehr, sehr gut angucken. Aber da wird eben die Frage sein, ob es eben am Ende reicht, um da am Ende dran zu bleiben. Und ich glaube, dann können wir, also gefühlt in keinem, keiner Partie wie in dieser Partie bisher, konnte man die eine Seite nicht analysieren, um immer mal wieder schon auf die andere Seite zu gucken. Und diese andere Seite, das ist eben der FC Schalke 04. Er steht auf Platz 1, hat 58 Punkte, 41 zu 25 Tore, 17 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen. Auf der Formtabelle ist man Platz 2, 3 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, wird im Knapp überholt vom SC Paderborn, haben aber beide 11 Punkte aus den letzten 5 Spielen gesammelt. Schalke ist weiterhin die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten Gegentoren, das sind 0,9 pro Spiel. Elversberg übrigens auf Platz 2 mit 1,1. Man blieb in dieser Saison zwölfmal ohne Gegentor. Übrigens genau wie. Wisst ihr, welche Mannschaft in der 2. Liga auch zwölfmal ohne Gegentor blieb? Einfach mal.
Nicht Nürnberg.
Ich hätte es tatsächlich so direkt nicht erwartet. Es ist Hertha BSC.
Oh, okay.
Das fand ich schon sehr, sehr spannend, ehrlich gesagt. Man hat die dritthöchste Klärungsrate pro Spiel. Also sie liegt bei 31,3. 909 Klärungen. Nur Fürth und Kiel haben mehr. Und da sieht man ja schon einen sehr großen Unterschied in den Tabellen. Und man muss eben sagen, trotz Verletzungs-Sorgen, also ohne Cartridge und ohne Dzeko, außer dem Gelb-Sperren bei Karaman und Aihahn für die Gummi und Sanchez ins Spiel gekommen sind, gewinnt man dieses Spiel. Und man muss ja, glaube ich, ihr habt eben schon mal gesagt, bei Schalke, da hat man so eine Bissigkeit gemerkt, vor allem ja eigentlich nach diesem unberechtigten Platzverweis, das muss man ja einfach sagen. Es ist ja umgekehrt. Petkov trifft einen Daje und nicht umgekehrt. Und trotzdem schafft man es nach dieser Unterzeit sehr, sehr schnell, das 2.1 zu erzielen und dann ja wirklich das zu machen. Schalke am besten schafft nämlich, sich ja auf ihre defensive Stabilität zu bewegen. Lisa, wir haben mal Anfang des Jahres so ein bisschen provokant nachgefragt, ob es bei Schalke vielleicht doch noch mal so eine Delle gibt, ob vielleicht die Euphorie am Ende, ja, ihn so ein bisschen selber das Messer in den Rücken rammt. Ich glaube, wir können sagen, wie bei so vielen in dieser Saison, lagen wir da ziemlich falsch.
Ja, würde ich jetzt mal so unterschreiben an der Stelle. Ja, ich finde es beeindruckend, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also gerade bei großen Traditionsvereinen, wie Schalke das ja auch einer ist, geht das ja auch schnell, dass es dann mal kippt, wenn vielleicht das ein oder andere Spiel nicht so läuft, wenn es irgendwie Rückschläge gibt, wenn du Verletzungen hast, wenn auch Dinge einfach mal gegen dich laufen. Und ich würde wirklich sagen, in Elbersberg ist erstmal einiges gegen Schalke gelaufen. Aber ich habe das ja schon angeteased von meiner kleinen Antwort zu Elbersberg. Die wirft halt gerade nichts um. Also man hat das Gefühl so, das ist zumindest mein Gefühl, wenn ich gerade Schalke gucke, da kann kommen, was will, das haut die nicht um. Die ziehen, wie jetzt hier in Elbersberg, eher noch mehr raus und haben richtig Bock. Ich will auch gar nicht wieder mit Mentalität. Ich glaube, das kennen wir alle und das haben wir auch schon zu oft an zu vielen Stellen gehört. Aber das ist für mich gerade so der Inbegriff von, da stimmt einfach so viel sportlich, was da an Qualität drinsteckt. Selbst wenn du hast die Ausfälle ja gerade aufgezählt, dass sie auch das auf der einen Seite wegstecken und sportlich gesehen, ja. Aber ich finde gerade so dieses Teamgefüge, da stimmt einfach so viel insgesamt zwischen Trainer, Mannschaft, Fans. Und das ist dann so eine klassische Situation von, du schwätzt von Erfolgserlebnis zu Erfolgserlebnis, wenn man die Bilder gesehen hat nach Abwurf. Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, da wurde der Aufstieg ja schon gefeiert, aber gefühlt wurde da der Aufstieg schon gefeiert. Guck ein bisschen neidisch dahin und würde mir das auch mal wieder wünschen. Auf der anderen Seite macht es auch einfach Bock. Also das muss ich so ehrlich schon auch sagen. Für mich Schalke so ein Verein, der einfach ganz klein in die 1. Liga gehörte, wo ich jetzt mit Blick auf Tabelle und Restprogramme und so schon sagen würde, ja, man darf sich jetzt noch nicht ausruhen. Aber ich sehe da jetzt gar nicht mehr so große Gefahren, um es vielleicht so zu formulieren und freue mich da.
Ja, man muss glaube ich auch sagen, also zwischenzeitlich mit diesem 1 zu 0 für Elbersberg hatten die sich an Schalke auch vorbei geschoben. Jetzt hat man eben 6 Punkte Abstand, beziehungsweise waren gleich– nee, da waren vorbeigezogen bei besseres Torverhältnis, so rum, Punkt gleich, aber eben vorbeigezogen. Und jetzt hat man eben 6 Punkte Abstand auf Elbersberg, 5 Punkte auf Hannover 96 auf Platz 3, einen auf Paderborn. Also es war auch schon wichtig, dieses Spiel, glaube ich, zu gewinnen. Was ich da ganz interessant finde, finde diese Streuung, die wir im Abstiegskampf in den Torverhältnissen haben, die haben wir da oben gar nicht mal so. Also das finde ich auch schon sehr interessant. Also ich mache es der Vollständigkeit, aber auch gehe ich das auch einmal durch. Wir haben Schalke auf Platz 1, 58 Punkte, Tordifferenz ist 16, 41 zu 25 Tore Paderborn, 57 Punkte, 31 zu 34, äh, 51 zu 34, Tordifferenz von 17, Hannover 96, 53 Punkte, 49 zu 35, 14 Tordifferenz, Elbersberg, äh, 52 Tore, 49 zu 32, also 17 Tore und dann Darmstadt, da würde ich dann den Cut machen, 50 Punkte, ähm, 50 zu 34 Tore, 16 Tordifferenz. Also was wir da unten haben, dass wir Punkte technisch sehr beieinander sind, Torverhältnismäßig sehr weit oder viele Vereine mit gleichen Punkten, unterschiedliche Torverhältnisse, ist da eben schon so ein bisschen anders. Noch, in Anführungszeichen, ähm, aber da siehst du eben den klaren Cut zu Hertha BSC, die dann halt wirklich in Anführungszeichen nur um 9 Punkte oder um 9 Tore positives Torverhältnis haben. Ähm, also du siehst da eben, um so ein bisschen Punkt rund zu machen, dass es schon sehr, sehr wichtig war, dieses Spiel zu gewinnen. Man muss da sagen, ähm, nachdem man eben gegen Hannover und Darmstadt nur unentschieden spielen konnte, war es, glaube ich, auch wichtig, den Sieg jetzt trotzdem zu holen. Also es gab ja schon in Anführungszeichen so ein bisschen, im Gegensatz eben zu der Hinrunde, da so, dass man dem Gegner da so ein bisschen die Chance gegeben hat, an sich näher ranzukommen. Aber da muss man jetzt eben sagen, das haben sie dann gegen Elvesberg anders gemacht. Und sie haben eben die Möglichkeit, wenn wir eben drauf gucken, sie spielen dann als nächstes gegen Preußen Münster. Und dann kommt wirklich, gleich kann man in Anführungszeichen ein bisschen sagen, dass die Partie, die frühzeitig so ein bisschen die Meisterschaft entscheiden könnte. Wir werden darüber reden in zwei Wochen. Die Partie gegen den SC Paderborn. Also ich glaube, das wird einfach so ein bisschen der Vorentscheid, wer da vielleicht in den Mai hinein die Nase ein bisschen vorn hat. Aber also das ist wirklich der einzige Verein, wo ich jetzt auch aufgrund des Restprogramms Münster, Paderborn, Düsseldorf, Nürnberg, Braunschweig, doch aufgrund der Stabilität, die sie mit sich bringen und die ganzen– also wir haben bei Fortuna Düsseldorf darüber geredet, man darf sich nicht immer dahinter ausruhen, Verletzungen und so. Und da muss ich sagen, da muss– klar, es ist was ganz anderes, ob du auf Platz 1 oder unten auf Platz 16 oder so stehst. Aber das hat mir zum Beispiel nach dem Karlsruh-Spiel sehr, sehr gut gefallen, wie er da auch gesagt hat, ey, ich habe Spieler, alle Spieler im Kader, auf die kann ich mich erstmal verlassen. Und ich glaube, selbst in Sanchez, der seit der Partie, glaube ich, gegen Elbersberg in der Hinrunde eben nicht mehr in der Startelf stand, da konntest du hier in die Startelf stellen. Und das ist dann natürlich auch, ja, einfach nochmal ein Zeichen für die mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, die eben absolut intakt ist. Und wo du einfach merkst, da wird dann eben auch nach dem Rückstand, nach der Unterzahl, wird halt da jeder Schritt gegangen. Sehr beeindruckend, finde ich.
Ja, definitiv. Also ich hatte phasenweise etwas den Eindruck, dass Schalke, ist ja auch nicht schlimm, aber sehr so das macht, was es halt braucht und sich dabei aber auch nicht verausgabt. Jetzt aber im Schlussspurt zeigt, dass es völlig okay ist, so zu agieren, weil sie eben einfach wirklich noch zwei, drei Gänge in der Hinterhund hatten, in die sie hochschalten können, ganz offensichtlich. Und Eva finde auch genau das, das ist ein bisschen das Gegenbeispiel zu Klagen über Schiedsrichter und Verletzungen, da einfach wirklich durchzuziehen, weil es wäre auch legitim gewesen irgendwie, du holst Jeko in der Winterpause, der verletzt sich in der Länderspielpause, darauf hinzuweisen, dass das irgendwie schmerzhaft ist, oder dieser Ausfall nicht zu kompensieren, oder wie auch immer. Und jetzt da eben in unverdienter Unterzahl, so ein Top-Spiel abzuliefern, ist einfach phänomenal. Ich habe es wirklich nicht mit Schalke, aber da kann man wenig dran finden, was man aussetzen könnte. Das finde ich echt sehr, sehr stark und absolut uneingeschränkt verdiente Tabellenführung.
Das kann man, glaube ich, dann wirklich auch einfach mal mit Miron Muslitsch und ja generell auch Frau Bauman und Co. einfach nochmal attestieren, was wir vielleicht an anderen Standorten nicht gesehen haben. Aber da gibt es halt trotzdem eine Weiterentwicklung und eben ja auch so eine Art von Plan B, was wir eben an anderen Stellen vielleicht nicht unbedingt haben. Aber den muss man eben schon eine gute Reaktion auf Rückschläge auch irgendwie attestieren. Und ich hätte es tatsächlich nicht gedacht, dass sie so noch mal in diesen Saisonentspurt reingehen. Klar, wir wissen auch da noch nicht, was passiert in den letzten fünf Spielen. Aber sie sind eben in einer für diese Liga durchaus komfortableren Ausgangslage, als man vielleicht erwartet hat. Vorsichtig gedacht. Und ich muss weiterhin einfach sagen, ich finde die Art und Weise von Miron Muslić, das passt einfach zu Schalke. Also der hat es, glaube ich, geschafft, wird es mal wirklich ein bisschen kitschig ausgedrückt, eine ganze Reihe an Generationen hinter sich zu versammeln, die Schalke 04 zwischendurch verloren hatte. Und das macht er nicht mit dem allerschönsten Fußball der Liga. Aber ich weiß halt noch, ich habe vor der Saison gesagt, Schalke muss den Ernst der Lage realisieren und dass sie eben nicht gegen Real Madrid in der Champions League spielen, sondern einfach erstmal ums blanke Überleben in der 2. Liga oder ganz dringend aufpassen müssen. Und man muss da ja einfach noch mal sagen und vielleicht so ein bisschen den Rückschluss auf Christian Eichner am Anfang zu ziehen. Auch wenn natürlich Schalke nie in der Situation war, der jetzt in Karlsruhe war oder Amine Bielefeld in dieser Saison. Aber du schaffst mit Miron Muslice auch eine Identität für den Klub. Und das ist etwas, was Schalke ganz, ganz lange und zwar nicht diese klassische ihr haben Aloha und Kumpel und dies und das, sondern du schaffst halt trotzdem erstmal eine Identität von einem, von Wohlfühlsein in diesem Verein. Und das ist eben etwas, was Schalke ganz, ganz lange und ich glaube, dass das übertreibe ich auch nicht wirklich gefehlt hat. Und das ist für mich auch, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wenn, wie sie sich dann in der Bundesliga schlagen, weil wir eben in der Vergangenheit immer wieder gesehen haben, wenn du jemanden hast, hinter dem du dich versammeln kannst. Das kann schiefgehen, wie im Fall von Leverknecht in zwei Fällen so. Aber du kannst eben auch sehen, dass es klappen kann. Klar, Miron Muslitsch ist noch lange nicht auf dem gleichen Weg wie Frank Schmidt. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns schon alle einig. Eine Saison reicht dafür nicht. Aber er hat eben jetzt schon einen Status, den eben, wie gesagt, ganz lange kein Schalke-Trainer mehr vor ihm hatte. Tja, schauen wir mal, was das wird. Und dann leite ich nochmal über und zwar zu einer Mannschaft, wo man eigentlich auch dachte, sie befinden sich in einer sehr komfortablen Situation im Ausstiegskampf. Die Redes von Darmstadt 98, die mussten am Samstagabend die erste Heimliederlage der Saison hinnehmen. Gegen Hannover 96. In diesem Topspiel dominiert 96 einen Tag vor seinem 130-jährigen Geburtstag, den SVD regelrecht Neubauer in der 14. und Torderson in der 55. Minuten schießen, die Hannoveraner auf Platz 3. Allerdings musste auch Hannover dreimal verletzungsbedingt wechseln. Kellmann kam in der 20. Minute für Pichlard, Gieter in halb so zwei für Nawrocki und Torschütze. Torderson musste in der 73. Minute durch Matsuda ersetzt werden. Wir blicken zunächst auf Darmstadt 98. Die sind jetzt auf Platz 5 abgerutscht, haben 50 Punkte, 50 zu 34 Tore, 13 Siege, 11 unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen in der Formtabelle. Da ist man inzwischen auch auf Platz 14 abgerutscht. Nur ein Sieg in den letzten fünf Spielen, zwei unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Nach der Niederlage gegen Bielefeld am vergangenen Wochenende, die neben der, ja, ich würde schon sagen, zumindestens für Kläfisch fragt, für den Gelb-Sperre und eben noch für Liedberg eben auch ein Dämpfer im Aufstiegskampf bedeutete, Cofeld dann Papella, Schmidt und Lakenmacher starten lassen, Richter tatsächlich auf der Bank. Vor dieser Niederlage gegen Bielefeld gab es eben die Unentschieden gegen Schalke und Magdeburg. Lisa, ich würde mal bei dir anfangen. Im Forum, wo so ein bisschen diskutiert, wird Darmstadt 98 jetzt doch nervös, nachdem man ja doch so ein bisschen ausgerufen hatte, es geht jetzt doch dann um den Ausstieg.
Ja, du hast die Zahlen ja gerade ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ich finde, das ist so das klassische Beispiel von, die lassen jetzt Federn. Also das, was Anna so ganz gut beschrieben hat bei Schalke, die schaffen es jetzt noch, den Gang hochzuschalten oder die schaffen es jetzt noch, auch Spiele, die vielleicht nicht für sie laufen, noch zu drehen und da einfach dann nicht diese Rückschläge zu bekommen. Das ist, glaube ich, genau das Gegenteil jetzt bei Darmstadt, was wir so ein bisschen beobachten können an der Stelle. Mich hat das ehrlicherweise echt überrascht, wie das gegen Hannover gelaufen ist. Das war jetzt ja noch nicht mal– also du kannst verlieren und du kannst irgendwie knapp verlieren, unglücklich verlieren. Ich glaube, die Spiele kennen wir alle, wo man am Ende dann sitzt, naja, es ist irgendwie blöd gelaufen. Aber das fand ich schon in der Art und Weise überraschend. Also das hatte ich so nicht auf dem Zettel, ehrlicherweise. Nicht nur, weil Darmstadt so heimstark ist. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ob du den Fact gebroppt hast, aber erste Heimpleite seit elf Monaten, das fand ich auch eine krasse Zahl. Und so wie das Spiel dann lief und das, was da alles irgendwie gefehlt hat, das hätte ich so nicht erwartet. Ich fand irgendwie schon auch bezeichnend, du hast es ja gerade auch so ein bisschen angeteasst, man hat da jetzt schon deutlich nach oben geblickt, dass auch wirklich so der Frust sehr, sehr, sehr rauskam. Es ist ja jetzt noch nichts verloren und so. Also ich verstehe das ein Stück weit gleichzeitig. Da war ich dann noch überrascht, wie angepisst alle da waren. Ein Stück weit, ja klar, muss man angepisst sein. Das hat mich dann doch so ein bisschen, ja ich weiß gar nicht, ob es verwundert das richtige Wort ist. Natürlich ist man nicht happy in der Niederlage, aber so die Härte, die da irgendwie auch drin steckte in dem ein oder anderen Satz, auch gerade weil Hannover natürlich gefeiert hat und dass das natürlich dann auch nicht so gut da ankam, verstehe ich alles, aber könnte so ein bisschen den Schluss zulassen mit so, ja man hat da jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen Aufstiegsangst, wenn man es psychologisch irgendwie einsortieren will. Aber ja, also ist jetzt für mich, also hatte ich so nicht kommen sehen in der Art und Weise und spricht jetzt für mich gerade nicht so sehr viel für Darmstadt, wenn ich mich auf Top 2, 3, also ehrlicherweise Top 2, ist ja schon ein kleiner Abstand, du hast es gesagt, bis Paderborn auf 2, 7 Punkte, bis auf Schalke 8 Punkte. Hannover, klar, das waren jetzt die Big Points, ich glaube, da können wir ja gleich nochmal ein bisschen genauer drüber sprechen, aber ein bisschen aufstiegsflatter oder wie hattest du es gerade genannt, würde ich schon unterschreiben an der Stelle.
Anna, wie siehst du das?
Ich glaube, dass Darmstadt 98 ergebnismäßig absolut überperformt hat in dieser Saison. Ich finde, die haben oft– spielerisch schon überzeugt– Tore gemacht nach Standards oder nach so, okay, what the fuck, warum macht er denn jetzt diese Tortore?
Und ich glaube, wenn du aufhörst, diese Tore zu machen, bei denen einfach in 98 Prozent der Fälle kein Tor rausspringt, dann kriegst du ein Problem. Also Isaac Lidberg hat– das war, glaube ich, in der Hinrunde hatte er irgendwie orientiert an seinen Expected Goals– vier Tore mehr gemacht, als es überhaupt wahrscheinlich gewesen wäre. Und ich glaube, dass diese Statistik Darmstadt einfach einhoh… Ich bin sehr froh, dass die die Werte in der Mannschaft auf lange Sicht geholt haben und dass sie jetzt so ein bisschen das Nachsehen haben im Vergleich zu Mannschaften, bei denen das eher zueinander passt. Ich weiß, dass diese XG-Werte, die werden unterschiedlich erhoben und unterschiedliche Plattformen kommen dazu, unterschiedliche Faktoren. Ich würde im Kontext Damenstadt 98 trotzdem die These aufstellen wollen, dass sich gerade zeigt, dass die Ergebnisse, die sie an die Tabellenspitze geführt haben, zusammenhängen damit, dass die Ergebnisse besser waren als die spielerische Leistung oder das zu erwartende Ergebnis.
Ja, finde ich auf jeden Fall ein provokant wie auch interessanten Take, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich musste daran tatsächlich auch nochmal, ich muss einmal nochmal in Verbindung zur Bundesliga ziehen. Bitte, liebe Darmstadt-Fans, ist es rein sportlich gemeint, nicht irgendwie auf anderer Basis, aber hoffne einen. Bei denen passiert gerade genau das Gleiche, was wir so schön Regression zur Mitte nennen, nämlich eine Leistung über einen Großteil der Saison, wo man sich da fragt oder wo man vielleicht positiv überrascht ist, wo man auch gute, weil ich möchte trotzdem auch sagen, es waren trotzdem auch gute Taktiken im Spiel dabei, es gab gute Einstellungen von Kohfeldt auf die jeweiligen Gegner, natürlich eben auch gute individuelle Leistungen, aber du kommst jetzt in eine Phase rein, wo du dich ein bisschen fragst, aber was war denn eigentlich auch der Plan? Also ich weiß, das hat Matthias Kneifel eben mir auch so nach dem Bielefeldspiel, das hat er ja auch in der Gruppe bestätigt, also musste da schon sagen, diese 1-0-Führung war eben per se schon mal schmeichelhaft, ist halt eher ein Fehler der Bielefelder, als dass es wirklich von der Qualität der Darmstädter war. Und dann muss man sagen, gab es eine zweite Halbzeit, in der Darmstadt nichts mehr gemacht hat, ehrlich gesagt. Also in dem offensiv, wie auch generell, jegliche taktische Einstellung fehlte, und das war gegen Hannover Minute 1 so. Nur, dass eben diesmal kein Ball durchgerutscht ist, um es mal provokant auszudrücken. Und das ist halt was, was ich sonst bis auf, nee, was ich sonst eigentlich wenig gesehen habe von Darmstadt in dieser Saison. Und was, glaube ich, wo du dann eben einen Florian Kohfeldt siehst, der vor allem im Spiel sehr emotional reagiert, wo ich sagen muss, ich finde seine Aussagen wiederum nach dem Spiel, wo er meistens sehr, also wie so ein anderes Gesicht zeigt, finde ich meistens um einiges spielbezogener als die Reaktion, die er zum Teil im Spiel zeigt. Ich weiß immer nicht, ob er dadurch irgendwie anstacheln will, ob das einfach seine Art ist und dann vielleicht im Umkehrschluss irgendwie selber in sich geht. Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin dafür auch ehrlich gesagt zu weit weg von 98. Aber ich finde das jetzt wirklich zwei Spiele, die mir als Darmstadt-Fan wirklich Sorgen machen würden und wo ich auch durchgelesen habe, so ein bisschen, wo halt wirklich die Frage war, also man kann ja verlieren, ihr habt es eben schon gesagt, aber ich frage wirklich bei beiden Partien, was war denn die Idee? Also ich habe zum Beispiel, wenn ich schon zweimal wechseln muss, klar kannst du das vielleicht leistungstechnisch von Marco Richter irgendwie erklären, aber ich hätte den allein durch die Qualität, die er ja doch mitbringen kann, hätte ich den alleine auf dem Platz gelassen, ehrlich gesagt. Das habe ich irgendwie, ja, und die, also diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, die Darmstadt zwischendurch auch schon durchaus geschafft hat und das Gefühl hatte, es ist doch in größtenteils egal, wer vielleicht im Mittelfeld-Verbund raussteht, das fehlt ihnen irgendwie. Lisa?
Ja, ich glaube, was jetzt total spannend wird, wir haben ja eigentlich bei allen Teams auch so ein bisschen auf die letzten Spiele geblickt, ist halt wirklich an der Stelle auch das Restprogramm. Also klar, gegen Fürth, ich will nicht sagen, das ist ein wegweisendes Spiel so, das kann man gefühlt jetzt zu jedem Spiel sagen, aber das muss man natürlich auch gewinnen. Das könnte eine gute Gelegenheit sein aus Darmstads Sicht, um nochmal einen anderen Schnack wieder reinzubringen, um irgendwie Selbstvertrauen zu tanken, wenn man sieht, wie Fürth eben auch gerade spielt und wo die so stehen. Aber dann so richtig spannend ehrlicherweise, natürlich Elbersberg und letzter Spieltag, vielleicht der Reihenfolge nach, also als Nächstes jetzt in Fürth, dann zu Hause gegen Elbersberg, dann nochmal in Karlsruhe bei Preußen Münster. Auch nochmal ein spannendes Ding. Und am letzten Spieltag natürlich gegen Paderborn. Also ich finde, da sind jetzt noch so ein paar Momente dabei, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, die werden entscheidend. Aber ich glaube, gerade so die nächsten zwei Spiele gegen Fürth und Elbersberg könnten nochmal so ein bisschen Aufschluss geben über das, was du gerade schon so angeteased hast. Eva mit, was ist die Idee, wo soll es hingehen, was ist gerade los. Aber halt auch in der Konstellation, in der Tabelle. Also das finde ich wird jetzt nicht uninteressant, ehrlicherweise. Und auch da, ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich zu negativ bin, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt gerade so mit Darmstadt gehen würde.
Ja, es ist eben einfach so, dass sie sich die positive Ausgangslage, ich habe es am Anfang einmal gesagt, die haben sie jetzt halt zuletzt einfach leider ein bisschen hergegeben. Und klar, auch hier herrscht vielleicht anderer Druck als an anderen Standorten. Ja, also weniger, aber trotzdem muss man halt einfach rein sportlich sagen, dass da Fragezeichen bestehen bleiben. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was wir da jetzt sehen. Ich würde aber auch angesichts der Zeit sagen, liebe Darmstadt-Fans, bitte verzeiht es mir, wir schauen noch einmal auf Hannover 96. Die haben sich nämlich jetzt ja auf Platz 3 vorgekämpft. 53 Punkte, 49 zu 35 Tore, 15 Siege, 8 Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen. Eine Formtabelle auf Platz 5 mit 2 Siegen, 2 Unentschieden. Eine Niederlage, nachdem wir eben über das 1-1 gegen Elbersberg gesprochen haben. Ich würde es jetzt einfach als durchwachsen, neutral betrachten. Der natürlich schon ein komplett anderer Auftritt gegen Darmstadt. Wie gesagt, es ist die erste Mannschaft seit 11 Monaten, aber eben auch in dieser Saison, die es geschafft hat, Darmstadt zu Hause zu schlagen. Anna, ich weiß ja, du bist ja doch näher dran an Hannover 96, manchmal gerne, manchmal ungern, weiß ich nicht, wie man es ausdrücken möchte. Wie blickst du denn jetzt auf 96?
Insgesamt interessiert, würde ich sagen, weil ich übe mich jetzt diese ganze Folge einfach weiterhin in Diplomatie. Das, was ich an Hannover 96 und dem Umfeld sehr schätze, ist eine gewisse Unaufgeregtheit in Bezug auf so das eigene Selbstverständnis von Einzigartigkeit, weil ja Fußballfans gerne erzählen, wir sind der einzige Club in dem, und wir sind die einzige Fanszene, die und so weiter und so fort. Und so diese Sehnsucht danach, das ganz besondere Kerzchen auf der Bundesligatorte zu sein, das verspüre ich hier sehr selten und das schätze ich sehr, dass man hier einfach niedersächsisch vorgeht und halt am Wochenende zu den Spielen und das relativ unaufgeregt gestaltet. Auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite bemerke ich eine– vielleicht passt das auch dazu– die 2. Also das ist das zweitbeste Auswärtsteam. Die stehen jetzt ganz oben in der Tabelle. Die haben sich so aus einem immer währenden Mittelfeld jetzt auf einen Relegationsplatz vorgearbeitet. Sie kompensieren Verletzungsausfälle. Sie kompensieren immer wieder doch Schiedsrichterunglück, möchte ich schon sagen. Dass sich das häuft und dass ich nachvollziehen kann, dass da Unzufriedenheit besteht über die Entscheidungen des Schiedsrichtergespanns. Und dass darüber irgendwie sich nicht angemessen gefreut wird, finde ich. Also ich am anderen Ende der Tabelle als Braunschweigerin habe dann manchmal so den Eindruck, ich bin die Verhungernde und derjenige mit viel Essen sagt, es schmeckt ihm nicht so richtig. Und daran stoße ich mich manchmal, weil ich finde, dass 96 insgesamt wirklich eine richtig gute Saison spielt. Ich sehe die gerne Fußball spielen. Ich finde, dass Tiz ein Upgrade ist im Vergleich zu Leite. Ich finde, dass Tiz die Mannschaft insgesamt stabil hält, trotz diesem ganzen Schmatke-Gemache und diesem internen Hin und Her und der dann doch immer wieder latenten Unruhe im Umfeld des Vereins. Ich finde den Fußball, den sie spielen, spannend, dass sie zu wenig Tore machen im Vergleich zu den Chancen, die sie sich rausspielen. Mag so sein, scheint jetzt aber am Ende eben doch ja insgesamt in die richtige Richtung zu führen. Und ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, wie die jetzt den Schlussspurt gestalten, weil ich da schon das Potenzial sehe, jetzt am Samstag gegen Paderborn noch mal einen richtig großen Schritt zu machen. Ich sehe aber auch die Möglichkeit, dass sie wieder in so eine Liturgie fallen und dann am Ende halt so 5-Star werden, weil irgendwie weiß man auch nicht so richtig. Und ich würde, glaube ich, jetzt abschließen damit, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass sich diese Spitzengruppe teilt in Mannschaften, die sehr selbstbewusst aufsteigen wollen und sich trauen, das zu artikulieren und sich davon ziehen lassen. Und Mannschaften wie Darmstadt oder auch Hannover, bei denen das zwar irgendwie klar ist, aber ach nee, dafür ist man irgendwie zu bescheiden. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das am Ende den Unterschied machen wird.
Ich glaube, ich habe sehr selten gehört, dass jemand Hannover 96 als bescheiden bezeichnet hat. Das finde ich sehr interessant. Also mal zum Endspurt im Samstag gegen den SC Paderborn. Ich sage mal so, da dürftest du dir nicht erlauben, eine schlechte Effizienz an den Tag zu legen. Das setzt einfach schon mal mit Blick auf das 4 zu 3 vom SC P gegen Magdeburg als Hinweis. Dann muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen, spielt man gegen drei Teams für die die Saison– ich sage es jetzt nochmal, Lisa, mach damit, was du willst, mehr oder weniger vorbei ist. Also je nachdem– Ich verschrei das nicht.
Also als Clubfan, man hat schon alles erlebt. Ich glaube, das versteht auch nur Clubfans.
Nee, ich verstehe das wirklich auch. Man spielt eben gegen Paderborn, dann spielt man auswärts bei Karlsruhe. Haben wir eben schon mal drüber geredet. 40 Punkte. Das Ding müsste eigentlich durch sein. Zu Hause gegen Preußen Münster. Und dann auswärts beim VfL Bochum. Und zu Hause gegen Nürnberg. Gerade Bochum-Nürnberg waren zwei Partien in der Hinrunde, wo man einmal gewinnen muss. Also eigentlich zweimal gewinnen muss. Einmal verschießt man einen entscheidenden Elfmeter und einmal lässt man Nürnberg zweimal einfach viel zu viel Raum. Mal schauen, wie sich das jetzt in der Rückrunde gestaltet. Aber wie gesagt, da muss man sagen, also ich gehe davon aus, für drei von vier Vereine geht es da um die goldene Ananas. Ehrlich gesagt noch, weil ich auch wenn Bochum rechnerisch noch lange nicht gerettet ist. Ich sage da gerne nochmal, für mich haben sie drei Punkte zu viel seit dem Sieg gegen Braunschweig. Sorry Anna, ich muss es einmal noch noch sagen, weil da also wie gesagt, der Rest nimmt sich da irgendwann noch die Punkte mit. Das sollte dann eventuell da gegessen sein. Ich muss sagen, ich war Teil der Menschen, die Hannover's Leistung zuletzt etwas kritisiert haben. Weil ich fand, boah ja vielleicht spätestens seit dem Duell gegen Dynamo Dresden, hat man zwar die Siege geholt, aber sowohl die Partie gegen Bielefeld, die man zwar gewinnt, als auch die Partie gegen Braunschweig, Anna widerspricht mir da gerne, aber war jetzt kein, ach das muss man gewinnen, und da fehlte einfach die Effizienz vom Tor, dass es nicht 3 oder 4-0 aufs geht. So, wäre mein Take zu den beiden Spielen auf jeden Fall. 1-1 gegen... gut, ich glaube, wirklich, wirklich wichtig war, dass man dieses Spiel gegen Schalke ganz spät noch den Punkt holt. Sonst reden wir von einer anderen Ausgangslage, nicht nur, weil man eben zwei Punkte weniger hat, einen Punkt weniger hat, sondern eben, weil man auch generell eine Tabelle da anders wider angelassen hat. Und auch gegen Elbersberg trotz dieses Elfmeters nicht zu verlieren war sicherlich wichtig. Aber jetzt eben diesen Sieg zu holen, ich denke mal, das wird dann doch nochmal ausschlaggebend sein. Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht, was wir da... Also bei Hannover bin ich mir unsicher, ehrlich gesagt, was wir da vom Rest noch erwarten können, um das vielleicht abzubinden. Lisa, guck mal, ich wollte dich gerade sogar noch weiterfangen, da hebst du hier schon virtuell die Hand.
Ja, ich finde mich tatsächlich bei Hannover so ganz spannend, dass es so im Verlauf ja immer wieder so kleinere Rückschläge, sage ich mal, gab. Aber ich da immer das Gefühl hatte, die haben sich immer wieder zu einem guten Moment, sage ich mal, da auch rausgearbeitet. Also ich habe oder wir hatten das ja vorhin, als wir über Pförd gesprochen haben, das vergisst man, finde ich, so schnell. Die haben einfach gegen Pörd verloren. Das waren so Momente, da hätte so eine Saison auch kippen können. Und da hatte ich das Gefühl, hat man das bei Hannover ganz gut immer wieder geschafft, dass das halt nicht passiert. Und du hast das gerade erwähnt, das 1-1 gegen Schalke war, glaube ich, auch so ein Moment. Und jetzt auch am Wochenende…
2-2, Entschuldigung, das 2-2 gegen Schalke.
Das Unentschieden. Und ich glaube, auch jetzt das Topspiel am Wochenende könnte so ein Moment sein, der dann natürlich total wegweisend ist aufgrund der Konstellation. Aber um auch jetzt nochmal zu untermauern, wie geht man in diesen Endspurt? Also mit Blick aufs Programm, ja, da ist viel möglich. Ich gucke denen auch sehr, sehr gerne zu. Also ich glaube, das hat Anna schon total schön zusammengefasst, was da irgendwie alles passiert ist dieses Jahr. Auch so den Titsball, den mag ich schon auch gerne. Guck ich auch ein bisschen neidisch manchmal, also ein bisschen nach Hannover. Mal gucken, der letzte Spieltag, dann gegen den Club. So wie die Gesamtgemengelage ist, glaube ich schon, das Hannover, das packt ehrlicherweise diese Saison, auch mit dem kleinen Poster, das es ja jetzt schon gibt. Für mich wäre dann eher der nächste Gedanke, ist das ein Team, das dann auch bundesligareif ist. Und das ist jetzt schon sehr, sehr weiter gedacht, I know. Aber da würde ich dann eher so die Zweifel vielleicht irgendwie sehen, dass ich da das Gefühl hätte, das wird dann schon sportlich. Also da müsste, glaube ich, im Sommer dann auch noch mal einiges passieren. Ich weiß, soweit sind wir noch gar nicht. Aber da bin ich irgendwie bei Hannover gedanklich schon so ein bisschen, wo ich zum Beispiel bei Schalke ein bisschen anderes Gefühl hätte, wenn wir jetzt schon über die Saison hinaus denken.
Anna, gerne.
Ja, würde ich beipflichten. Ich glaube, der einzige Verein, der diese Bundesliga-Reife jetzt schon andeutet, ist Schalke 04. Und dass diejenigen, die hinter Schalke rangieren, das tun, weil sie davon profitieren, dass andere nicht gepunktet haben. Also Eva, du hattest das ja skizziert, dieses Tief von Hannover, beziehungsweise gegen Fürth verloren, gegen uns nicht gut gespielt. Aber es reicht halt in der Zweien-Liga. Und diesen Faktor darfst du ja auch nicht rausrechnen, dass das irgendwie viel nicht nur mit Timing zu tun hat, wie lang sind deine guten und deine schlechten Phasen, sondern auch gegen wen gewinnst du diese Spiele. Und Hannover hatte bisher kein einziges Spitzenspiel gewonnen, bis jetzt Darmstadt. Und das war für mich immer ein Faktor zu sagen, dann reicht es halt nicht für oben. Weil irgendwie musst du ja gegen die Konkurrenz in der Zweiten Liga bestehen und nicht nur da oben landen, weil du gegen die Unteren deine Punkte holst und deine Konkurrenz irgendwie versiebt, sondern auch innerhalb der Liga gegen die Top-Teams bestehen. Und das war jetzt irgendwie ein ganz spannender Punkt, dass das in Darmstadt so überzeugend funktioniert hat. Paderborn ist, finde ich, noch mal ein anderes Niveau, weil die so archal spielen. Also es kann halt irgendwie, da fallen irgendwie mehr Tore und denen ist irgendwie mehr egal, ob sie Gegentore fangen. Das sind so andere Vorzeichen, unter denen dieses Spiel steht. Ich finde, alles unter Schalke ist wirklich sehr schwer zu prognostizieren. Weil wie gesagt, ich habe Hannover auch schon absolut nicht gut gesehen. Aber auch leidvoll erfahren, dass sie zwar einerseits darüber klagen, wir waren so gut, wir haben die Tore nicht gemacht. Und der Schiedsrichter war gemein zu uns. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite die Punkte holen, obwohl sie nicht gut spielen. Und dann gleicht es sich ja am Ende auch wieder aus. Also naja, gut, jetzt sind wir hier schon am Rechenschieber.
Ja, ich glaube, wirklich so der Punkt, den wir von dieser Sendung mitnehmen können, ist, wir machen keine Prognosen mehr. Wir sind ja zum Glück hier irgendwie keine Ärztinnen oder so, die hier der 2. Liga was attestieren müssen und sagen, hier, das verschreiben wir euch jetzt, bitte Rezept abholen. Ich finde, es macht es für uns als Besprechende immer wieder interessant, weil ich glaube, im Gegensatz, in Teilen der Bundesliga beispielsweise, haben wir sehr viel mehr Varianz drin. Trotzdem, ich sag das gerne noch mal, sag das natürlich auch immer ein, hier ist über die Qualität der 2. Liga aus, wenn die Hälfte des Teams zu diesem Punkt gegen den Abstieg spielt. Was ist natürlich schon mal vielleicht so als Hinweis für potenziell Wolfsburg und Heidenheim, vor allem für Wolfsburg, sehr kleine Hinweise. Das könnte eine Nummer werden. Also ich bin sowieso gespannt, weil ich kann mich nicht mehr an Wolfsburg in der 2. Liga erinnern. Ich weiß nicht, wie euch das geht. Aber ja, freuen wir uns schon mal drauf. Also generell, wenn man mal auf die 3. Liga schaut, das könnte eine Saison werden, nächste Saison. Es wird sicherlich eine kuriose 2. Liga. Aber das ist sie sowieso jedes Jahr.
Also wird nicht langweiliger.
Wird nicht langweiliger, gehe ich auch von aus. Aber welche Diagnose ich auf jeden Fall, wirklich auf jeden Fall stellen kann, ist, dass wir am Ende dieser Folge angekommen sind. Und es ist mal wieder länger als geplant, den Wunder. Ich danke als allererstes Lisa Höfer, dass sie mal wieder dabei war. Danke Lisa.
Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Einladen. Es hat total viel Spaß gemacht. Zeit ist verflogen. Und ja, schauen wir, was die letzten Spiele bringen.
Und dann bedanke ich mich auch bei Anna Lautenbach. Danke Anna, dass du auch wieder dabei warst.
Danke schön. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und dann hört ihr mich in zwei Wochen hier wieder. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund. Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.